c'est
bon chers collègues j'espère que vous
Avezé un bel été et que vous êtes bien
reposé en tout cas je suis ravi de vous
retrouver après cette pause estivale
l'ordre du jour de notre commission au
début de la prochaine session ordinaire
portera essentiellement sur l'examen des
10 avis budgétaires sur lesquels nos
rapporteurs et nos administrateurs
travaillent activement en ce moment
avant cela je rappelle qu'une délégation
composée de neuf commissaires se rendra
mardi et mercredi prochain au Bundestag
à Berlin pour y rencontrer nos collègues
allemands de la commission de l'économie
et de la Commission de la protection du
climat et de l'énergie le lendemain
jeudi 28 septembre orange convie une
dizaine de députés à participer à un
parcours fibre dans l'un de ses centres
parisiens j'invite les commissaires qui
sont intéressés à rapidement le dire
auprès du secrétariat pour cette visite
qui sera suivie d'un déjeuner avec
Madame Christelle edeman directrice
générale du groupe Orange par ailleurs
je vous informe que la commission des
affaires économiques examinera mercredi
4 octobre 2023 la proposition de loi
visant à baisser la facture énergétique
des Français et des entreprises sur le
territoire national ce texte étant
inscrit par le groupe rassemblement
national à l'ordre du jour des séances
qui lui sont réservées le jeudi 12
octobre je vous propose de désigner
monsieur Alexandre Loubé comme
rapporteur de la proposition de loi je
demande votre assentiment pas
d'objection bien monsieur Loubé vous
êtes donc nommé
rapporteur l'actualité économique est
caractérisée par la persistance de
l'inflation en particulier l'inflation
touchant les produits alimentaires alors
même que les tensions sur les prix des
matières premières des produits
manufacturés ou des services se font
moindre le gouvernement a donc annoncé
son intention d'intervenir par voie
législative un projet de loi sera soumis
au Conseil des ministres du 27 septembre
notre commission l'examinera mardi 3
octobre le texte sera inscrit à l'ordre
du jour de la séance publique le lundi 9
octobre selon les informations dont je
dispose ce projet de loi contiendra deux
éléments clés un premier article
permettant d'avancer les dates de
négociation entre les distributeurs et
les 75 plus gros industriels c'est je
crois une attente de plusieurs acteurs
économiques que nous allons écouter
aujourd'hui et cet article nous amènera
probablement à nous interroger ou pas
sur la nécessité de graver dans la loi
la date des négociations il est
peut-être temps en tout cas certains
acteurs le disent de donner plus de
flexibilité dans les années qui viennent
pour qu'il décide librement et
contractuellement des prochaines dates
de négociation en tout cas c'est un beau
débat qui nous attend à l'occasion de
cet article premier un second article
est venu s'ajouter à ce futur projet de
loi il concerne le prix des carburants
qui nous préoccupe tous un acteur de la
grande distribution ici présent a
déclaré le 12 septembre sur France
interre je cite sur le carburant comme
j'achète et je revends je ne peux pas
revendre à perte pour pratiquer le juste
prix je n'en ai pas le droit
contrairement à Total énergie par
exemple fin de citation à l'écoute des
acteurs économiques le gouvernement a
donc annoncé que les distributeurs de
carburant pourraient être autorisés à
vendre à perte dès le début du mois de
décembre pour une durée de 6 mois cette
disposition sera intégrée dans le texte
initial du projet de loi qui nous sera
SM
elle devrait pleinement satisfaire ce
qui ne se privent pas de dire dans les
médias la main sur le cœur qu'il dirige
une ONG qui aimerait en baisser les prix
mais que la loi les en empêche sur ce
projet de loi et sous réserve de son
dépôt je vous propose la nomination
d'Alexis iszard comme rapporteur je
demande l'assentiment de la salle pas
d'objection il est donc nommé rapporteur
en attendant que le rapporteur organise
son travail il m'assemblé pertinent
d'organiser avec tous les membres de
notre commission deux tables rondes pour
entendre certains des protagonistes
essentiels pour la détermination des
prix de l'alimentation protagonistes qui
ont plus l'habitude de se renvoyer la
balle par médias interposé plutôt que de
s'exprimer directement devant les
parlementaires nous débuterons donc
cette matinée par une table ronde
rassemblant des représentants éminents
de la grande distribution puis à partir
de 11h1 nous réunirons une table ronde
associant des organisations représentant
l'industrie agroalimentaire présentant
les habituelles réclamations je rappelle
que notre temps est contraint et que le
futur rapporteur aura tout loisir
d'entendre toute personne ou toute
organisation le sollicitant d'ici le 3
octobre en ce qui me concerne j'ai
choisi de recevoir les acteurs de la
grande distribution occupant les plus
fortes part part de marché dans notre
pays ainsi que des associations
représentant des industriels de taille
diverses pour la grande distribution
nous accueillons donc monsieur Alexandre
Bompard président directeur général du
groupe Carrefour président de la
Fédération du commerce et de la
distribution bienvenue Monsieur
Dominique chelcher présidentdeur général
de systmu bienvenu Monsieur Thierry
Cotillard président du Groupement les
Mousquetaires bienvenue à vous et
Monsieur Philippe Michot coprésident de
l'enseigne Leclerc bienvenue à vous
messieurs je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette table
ronde et d'avoir ainsi dégagé du temps
dans vos agendas avant de vous donner la
parole pour une intervention liminaire
de 5 minutes chacun grand maximum je le
précise parce que le temps est un petit
peu contraint je rappelle que les
orateurs des groupes pour ensuite vous
interroger en DISP en disposant pour
chaque question d'un temps global de 4
minutes qui inclut le temps de réponse
qui doit être d'une minute au moins pour
vous et donc j'incite les orateurs à
identifier précisément la personne euh
dont ils attendent la réponse et après
les orateurs de groupe je prendrai en un
seul bloc toutes les questions d'ividués
individuellement qui souhaitent
s'exprimer et comme nous avons une
seconde table ronde le temps accordé
pour chaque question sera limité minutes
précisément et vous pourrez répondre à
la totalité de ces questions à la fin de
notre table ronde monsieur Alexandre
Bompard
président la Fédération du commerce et
de la distribution vous avez la
parolei je je crois que Monsieur lev la
main donc je sais pas si il aura il aura
son temp de parole tout à fait comme les
tout à l'heure vous inquiétez
pas monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
de votre accueil mesdames et messieurs
les députés merci de votre présence
puisque vous m'y autorisé je vais
effectuer une une brève déclaration
liminaire d'abord permettez-moi de
souligner que je suis et je crois nous
sommes heureux de cet échange avec vous
heureux d'abord par la considération que
je dois et que nous nous devons à la
représentation nationale heureux aussi
car je crois important pour nous de
mieux faire connaître notre secteur
notre rôle nos contraintes nos métiers
et tout ce que nous faisons pour les
Français dans leur combat face à
l'inflation notre secteur est souvent
méconnu parfois caricaturé et notre
échange de ce matin qui montre que vous
êtes à l'écoute des entreprises
permettra j'en suis sûr de dissiper
certains malentendu vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président je m'exprime en
tant que président de la FCD mais
surtout en tant que président directeur
général de Carrefour groupe présent dans
43 pays avec vous le savez un très fort
ancrage en France puisque 1550000
personnes travaillent dans un de nos
6000 magasins sur le territoire un
groupe en pleine transformation de son
modèle depuis 5 ans monsieur le
Président vous avez parlé d'inflation et
vous avez raison au fond c'est le sujet
principal pour les Français depuis 18
mois et c'est l'urgence aujourd'hui nous
avons été collectivement les premiers à
alerté sur cette situation dès le milieu
de l'année 2021 quand les prix de
l'énergie et ceux des matières premières
augmentaient et que l'on voyait déjà les
effets des perturbations du commerce
international et des chaînes logistiques
avant même que la guerre en Ukraine nous
fasse basculer définitivement dans une
are d'hyperinflation parfois ces
expressions ont choqué mais nous avons
toujours eu ce discours de vérité et
nous avions notamment dit dès le début
de l'année que nous devions vivre cette
année encore avec l'inflation il n'y a
pas eu et il ne pouvait y avoir de
septembre vert il n'y aura pas de baisse
des prix cette année la crise du pouvoir
d'achat est là sous nos yeux car cette
hyperinflation c'est mon deuxième point
est un poison lent je ne vais pas
redonner les chiffres nous les
connaissons tous au-delà des chiffres
vous connaissez la réalité des
administrés dans vos circonscriptions de
plus en plus de Français basculent dans
la pauvreté les fin de mois sont devenus
des millions de mois un français sur de
saute des repas un Français sur 10
renonce à des produits d'hygiène de
première nécessité et cela ne fait
qu'empirer n'ayons aucun doute non plus
sur le fait que cette inflation
fragilise aussi les entreprises et dans
notre secteur vous le savez certains
acteurs sont en grande souffrance on
peut faire et c'est parfois normal
beaucoup de reproches à la grande
distribution mais on ne peut pas lui
reprocher de n'avoir rien fait face à
l'inflation depuis 2 ans parce que ce
sont nos clients parce que c'est notre
métier nous avons multiplié les
initiatives en accompagnant parfois les
demandes des pouvoirs publics en
réduisant nos marges sur les produits du
quotidien en constituant des paniers
complet pour répondre aux besoins de nos
clients en faisant des opérations à prix
coûtant en développant des gammes
accessibles si chacun l'a fait avec son
modèle tout le monde s'est engagé dans
cette démarche c'est aussi cette
observation au plus près du terrain du
comportement des clients qui nous a
conduit à prendre la parole sur des
sujets de régulation non pas pas pour
nous substituer à votre rôle mais parce
qu'il nous a semblé de notre
responsabilité d'attirer votre attention
sur les conséquences de certains
dispositifs et nous l'avons fait avec
comme seule boussole la défense du
pouvoir d'achat des Français vous
connaissez par exemple notre position
sur le DPH dans cette période de grande
souffrance des Français en matière de
pouvoir d'achat nous avons juste demandé
un moratoire d'un an à l'arrêt des
promotion promotion si essentielle au
sens premier du terme pour nos clients
dans une catégorie 75 % du chiffre
d'affaires est effectué par les cinq
mêmes entreprises toutes des
multinationales de même nous réitérons
le fait que tous les dispositifs qui
limitent notre pouvoir de négociation
avec les grandes multinationales ne vont
pas dans le sens de la protection du
pouvoir d'achat des Français voilà mon
état d'esprit ce matin dans l'immense
majorité où j'ai le bonheur d'être euh
il y a une grande confiance accordée au
rôle de la distribution et de ses
opérateurs et de d'ailleurs cela va de
paire avec beaucoup de stabilité des
normes et beaucoup de stabilité des
réglementations j'aimerais parfois qu'il
en soit de même dans notre beau pays et
je crois que ce type d'échange est une
bonne manière d'y parvenir merci
beaucoup de votre attention merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Directeur
Général je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Dominique chelcher président
directeur général de Système U c'est à
vous monsieur Bompar il faut éteindre
votre micro voilà et c'est parfait merci
monsieur le Président euh pour votre
invitation votre accueil et cette
opportunité qui nous vous a donné
d'échanger avec vous bonjour Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires alors donc
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler que je
suis le le PDG de de systemu et comme
nous sommes une coopérative de
commerçants indépendants je suis
moi-même donc toutes les semaines chaque
fin de semaine dans mon magasin face à
mes clients et face à mes collaborateurs
et euh ce que je note en cette rentrée
c'est véritablement euh une
préoccupation renforcée de nos
concitoyens en tout cas d'une d'une
grande partie d'entre eux qui font face
à une rentrée vraiment plus difficile
que jamais qui se
restreignne pour une grande partie et ce
phénomène s'accélère véritablement et
donc notre responsabilité à tous c'est
évidemment de trouver des solutions pour
accompagner ces Français qui sont qui
sont en difficulté le point
d'aggravation de la situation actuelle
est très clairement le sujet du prix du
carburant nous sommes avant tout nous
systèmeu présents dans les territoires
ruraux où la voiture est complètement
indispensable pour aller au travail pour
emmener ses enfants pour aller faire les
activités et aussi pour faire les cour
et donc le budget carburant pèse de plus
en plus et on a une responsabilité aussi
de trouver des solution par rapport à
cela même si j'observe en même temps et
ça c'est un signe de qui qui est
intéressant je je trouve que face à
toutes ces difficultés beaucoup de
français cherchent des solutions d'ENT
d'entre eux de de de coopération de
collaboration sur sur le terrain pour
faire face à cette situation qui qui
pourrait être difficile ma grande
question à moi c'est euh après une
période de de choix d'arbitrage
maintenant on est rentré dans une
période de restriction jusqu'à quand
pourront-ils supporter cette période de
restriction et j'observe peut-être en
cette rentrée du côté de nos
collaborateurs en tout cas c'est un
retour que j'ai ben une tension qui
grandit un peu avec les les
collaborateurs voilà le le le moindre
sujet se transforme vite en en exigence
très forte et on peut le comprendre mais
voilà je je je trouve qu'en terme
d'ambiance c'est à relever alors sur les
les les fameuses négociations
commerciales qui sont le premier objet
de de de cette rencontre aujourd'hui euh
bon tout d'abord rappeler comme mon
confrère Alexandre bonpard que notre
engagement depuis le début de cette
crise est est véritablement important ça
fait maintenant 1 an qu'on a mis en
place des dispositifs extrêmement
important pour accompagner les les
consommateurs ça se traduit chez Système
U par un panier à prix coûtant c'est la
caractéristique de notre opération
c'est-à-dire que sur les produits qu'on
qu'on met en jeu qui sont les meilleures
ventes à notre marque nous ne prenons
plus du tout de marge c'est c'est un
investissement extrêmement important
c'est un exemple de dispositif mais il y
en a de nombreux autres euh il y a une
question qui va vous être posée comme
vous l'avez décrit dans dans le le
projet de loi qui va vous être proposé
dans les prochains jours sur la
réouverture des négociations commer tout
d'abord moi je voudrais dire que je
regrette que les grands industriels les
grands industriels n'est pas répondu
favorablement ou massivement à l'appel
du gouvernement dès le printemps dernier
de réouvrir ses négociations comme nous
avions pu le faire en 2023 en 2023 nous
avait été proposé à tous les acteurs la
même chose tout le monde s'était engagé
très fortement à un moment où il fallait
prendre en compte pour tout le monde
cette inflation et et ces charges sur
les entre entreprise on l'a fait on a
travaillé dur toute l'année et on a
abouti maintenant que le phénomène
s'inverse et vous l'avez dit vous-même
dans votre propos liminire on trouvait
intéressant de pouvoir avec ceux qui le
pouvaient et et notamment les plus
importants pouvoir renégocier ça n'a pas
pu se faire et très concrètement nous
nous nous avons
reçu des des propositions je dire
infimes et et pas représentatives du du
du besoin qu'on les Français de trouver
de de de meilleures conditions
finalement dans dans dans les mag
donc euh de notre côté évidemment la
proposition d'avancer les négociations
et et de changer la date est évidemment
très intéressante euh mais il faut avoir
en tête l'idée suivante il faudrait pas
que ça se transforme si on avance ses
négociations il faut que ça se
transforme en un mieux pour les
consommateurs or aujourd'hui l'alerte
qu'on peut avoir c'est que les premiers
signaux que nous avons ns fournisseurs
ce sont des demandes de tarifs à la
hausse donc si le sujet est d'avancer
les négociations commerciales pour
qu'elles se concluent par de l'inflation
complémentaire plus vite pour les
Français c'est un point euh c'est un
point délicat donc ça euh la mesure n'a
véritablement de sens que si au bout du
compte le résultat de nos discussions de
nos échange de nos travaux permettent
effectivement d'avoir une amélioration
euh pour les Français merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Directeur
Général je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Thierry ctiard président du
Groupement les Mousquetaires c'est à
vous monsieur président réappuyer sur le
micro très bien c'est bon ouais monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés chers collègues donc merci de
nous permettre cet échange sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui est au cœur des
préoccupation des Français peut-être
commencer à présenter le Groupement des
Mousquetaires très synthétiquement on
est 3000 chefs d'entreprisees on emploie
150000 collaborateurs c'est plus de 4000
magasins et on est connu en France avec
nos 1850 Intermarchés et 300 Netto
situés au cœur des territoires la
particularité c'est qu'on intègre des
métiers Connex au métiers de
distributeur avec en particularité
le fait de détenir 60 usines qui
produisent les produits à nos marques à
Intermarché suite à l'inflation de
l'Ukraine on a été je pense à l'écoute
des pouvoirs publics pour accompagner
les hausses de prix subis par les
agriculteurs et les industriels en
acceptant de renégocier à la hausse en
dehors du cadre législatif donc c'est
une campagne 2022 à la hausse c'est une
campagne 2023 à la hausse et en cours de
l'année 2022 vous le savez ça été des
hausses additionnelles demandé par le
gouvernement l'inflation est arrivée
aujourd'hui à 21 % un niveau
difficilement sur portable pour une
grande partie des Français cette
situation on la vit en point de vente
elle est très difficile pour nos clients
et on craint évidemment que si la
contrainte continue sur le budget des
ménages cela entraîne de vraies
difficultés et une montée évidemment du
mécontentement aussi dès le mois de
janvier 2023 on a construit une offre de
500 produits à nos marques la plupart
fabriqués en France dans nos usines en
baissant nos prix de vente de l'ordre de
7 % en prenant sur nos marges et
maintenant ces 500 produits c'est ce qui
est le plus consommé par nos
consommateurs puisque ça représente 25 %
de leur p
le dispositif on l'a accompagné aussi de
produits frais de viande de poisson
comme on nos abattoirs nos propres
bateaux et on l'a fait en en reniant sur
nos marges et comme l'a indiqué
Dominique chelcher on a complété notre
dispositif en ajoutant à ces 500
produits de marque porp 500 produits de
marque national pour arriver à 1000
produits parallèlement on a toujours été
disponible pour échanger avec le
gouvernement et on est prêt à anticiper
les négociations 2024 si une loi le
propose sauf que pour accélérer la
négociation faut être deux et concernant
les 60 plus grands fournisseurs un seul
au moment où je vous parle nous a
adressé ces tarifs 2024 et
l'augmentation proposée c'est 10 % alors
que pour réaliser une négociation dans
de bonnes conditions pour les deux
parties le délai de 90 jours ce sera pas
de trop donc autant dire que si le 15
janvier était retenu comme date de fin
négociation il nous faut absolument
avoir des des industriels les tarifs à
une date autour du 15 octobre second
point si tout le monde était d'accord
pour accélérer ce serait bien évidemment
pour aboutir à des baisses de prix pour
le consommateur or les échanges que nous
avons aujourd'hui avec certaines
multinational nous font penser que les
tarifs seront à la hausse dans une
proportion pour commencer laanég entre 5
et 15 % alors qui croire les industriels
ou les distributeurs il y a bien sûr pas
de bon pas de méchant mais il y a des
réalités économiques qui sont
intéressante à analyser j'en veux pour
preuve nous on est implanté dans
quelques territoires en Europe au
Portugal première question que je leur
ai posé il y a 15 jours c'est de leur
dire vous en êtes où sur l'inflation ils
ont commencé comme nous avec un 15 point
en début d'année mais comme tout au long
de l'année la renégociation est possible
ils ont réussi à gommer 4 C points et
faire baisser l'inflation euh sur sur
les tarifs des des
consommateurs ce qu'il faut retenir
aussi c'est que si on fait l'addition
des hausses et des baisses des cours de
matières premières agricoles les
fameuses MPa alors on a des hausses hein
le port vous le savez tout ça mais on a
aussi des baisses on a estimé que la
moyenne de tout ça ça pouvait donner 1 à
2 % de baisse sur le périmètre des
grands groupes mais le vrai sujet je
pense que c'est pas tellement le sujet
des matières premières agricoles c'est
surtout la fameuse MPI la matière
première industrielle on y met le
gazélectricité le carton le papier et on
voit bien aujourd'hui que les prévisions
de hausse que nous-même on avait sur
notre pôle industriel c'est bien en
dessous au-dessus pardon de la réalité
l'électricité pour vous donner un
exemple tout le monde avait spéculé que
ça allait faire 150 % la réalité c'est
80 %. c'est la même chose pour le gaz le
carton le papier ce que vous vous devez
retenir finalement c'est que sur les
plus 9 % que nous avons concédé à nos
industriels au 1er mars la moitié est
liée au potentiel de surcût des MPI
c'est-à-dire 4 à 5 %. et la réalité
c'est qu'on aurait dû certainement
concéder simplement 2 à 3 % au vu de
l'évolution réelle que nous connaissons
actuellement donc on parle de baisse
logique à répercuter au français de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 % en particulier sur
les produits d'hygiène beauté pour
lesquels il y a évidemment pas de MPa et
donc en conclusion si on additionne les
MP à les MP les hausses et les baisses
alors on serait en mesure probablement
de demander au grand groupes de baisser
de l'ordre de 2 à 5 % sur certains
marchés pour obtenir ces baisses qui
nous paraissent légitime nous aurons
besoin de VOUS certaines multinationales
vont de nouveau imposer des hausses et
contester la réalité des indicateurs qui
sont pourtant de notoriété publique
certaines d'entre elles selon certaines
d'entre elles les Français n'achètent
pas assez cher leurs produits je
m'inscris en faux il y a des études
Eurostat le publie l'indice de prix des
produits proposés à la consommation en
France c'est 115 par rapport à d'autres
produits merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Philippe Michot co-président de
l'enseigne Leclerc c'est à
vous merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés merci de
nous accueillir je vais vous faire
gagner du temps parce que beaucoup de
mes collègues ont dit déjà la grande
majorité des des choses je vais essayer
de rajouter quelques points de précision
sur sur ce qui vient d'être dit et et
que l'on partage bien évidemment euh on
on nous venons de connaître depuis ces
dernières années une salve de
législation tout inflationniste les unes
des autres donc elles ont pas elles-mêm
et elles toute seule participer au au au
niveau d'inflation que l'on a
aujourd'hui bien évidemment mais elles y
ont participé ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que là on est en train de reparler
d'une niè loi à venir alors que que l'on
a jamais encore réussi à laisser le
temps nous montrer les effets des lois
précédentes elles se sont
accumulé et on ne sait même pas ce qu'il
y a aujourd'hui on parle de loi et on a
ouais enfin je je vais pas répondre
directement à ça
euh nous avons des lois et nous avons
des par exemple
des des clauses de révision de prix des
clauses de révision de prix qui devrait
aujourd'hui donner
plein pleine liberté à au prix de de de
baisser parce que les matières premières
industrielles et matières premières
agricoles baissent aujourd'hui nous
avons face à nous des industriels qui
refusent d'appliquer ces ces révisions
ces clauses de révision de prix à la
baisse alors que bien évidemment ils en
étaient tout à fait favorables à la
hausse
donc on veut juste attirer l'attention
qu'il faudrait tout d'abord regarder
jusqu'où ces lois peuvent apporter leurs
effets escomptés avant peut-être d'en
d'en remettreen remettre d'autres bien
évidemment je je partage ce qui a été
dit sur les seuls CGV ou plus exactement
la seule CGV que l'on a reçu à date pour
les négociation 2024 avec une hausse de
10 % et je rajouterai aujourd'hui que
par rapport au au tarifs que l'on peut
euh discuter négocier tout tout au long
de l'année en fonction de des
différences et je pense surtout au au
marque distributeur euh lorsque l'on
fait et lorsque l'on reçoit ces ces
hausses et ces baisses parce qu'il y en
a faut pas non plus je leuris il y a
quand même aussi des baisses liées aux
baisses de matières premières mais quand
on fait l'amalgame de tout et compondire
des volumes les hausses et les baisses
demandées nous avons à peu près une
inflation qui tourne autour de 3 et 5 %
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait
dire sans sans sans sans vraiment faire
de pronostic léger que on peut
s'attendre en 2024 à une inflation qui
tournera autour de 3 ou 4 %
euh et on craint aussi que d'ailleurs ça
puisse arranger quand même pas mal de
monde d'avoir une inflation
latente et qui dure comme ça quelques
années de cet ordre là voilà c'est à peu
près la seule chose que j'ai à rajouter
sur les propos
tout à fait efficace de mes collègues
merci beaucoup monsieur le coprésident
je je me permets de rebondir parce que
vous avez dit il faudrait regarder
l'effet des lois avant d'en voter des
nouvelles je regarde que Michel Édouard
leclard ne soit pas présent avec nous ce
matin pour pouvoir en débattre parce que
j'avais quand même le sentiment à
l'écouter sur beaucoup de matin radio
c'était lui qui demandait un certain
nombre de changements législatifs mais
peut-être que j'ai mal compris ce que
vous avez dit et les collègues pourront
vous interroger plus en détail sur le
sujet mais en tout cas je regrette de ne
pas pouvoir avoir cet échange très
direct suite suite au au au au Matinal
que j'ai pu entendre et que nous avons
pu tous entendre je vous propose de
passer sans plus attendre aux orateurs
de groupe nous allons commencer avec
Monsieur Frédéric descrosay pour le
groupe renaissence donc je vous le
rappelle c'est une durée maximale de 4
minutes par orateur de groupe inclus la
réponse des personnes qui sont invitées
et euh donc je vous incite à faire cours
à bien cibler la personne euh que vous
interrogez et euh vous organisez votre
temps de 4 minutes comme vous le
souhaitez merci Monsieur des Croisille
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs de prendre le temps de
de cet échange ce matin
pour faire vite je vais rappeler deux
trois
principes avec lesquels si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord dites simplement non je
conteste et ensuite vous posez une
question ma question porte sur le droit
applicable est-ce que vous êtes bien
d'accord avec le fait que un justiciable
quel qu'il soit ne peut pas ne pas
appliquer une loi au motif qu'il en
conteste le
fondement si vous le contestez je VO ils
disent oui monsieur est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le fait que vous êtes des
représentants de personne morale qui
doivent obéir au même principe si vous
contestez une loi qui est adoptée que
vous en contestez même le fondement
juridique vous devez l'appliquer dans
l'attente d'une éventuelle issue par des
autorités saisies je les vois dire oui
monsieur descosill sur cette base
qu'attendez-vous du développement des
sociétés basé à l'étranger société
d'achat je pense à EURELEC Eureka et
Everest et est-ce que vous démz les
témoignages qui nous perviennent selon
lesquells les industriels qui sont
convoqués convoqués à Madrid à Bruxelles
ou à Amsterdam sont reçu par des gens
qui leur disent ici le droit français ne
s'applique pas quelqu'un souhait-il
répondre ne vous battez pas non non on
va pas se battre allez-y on a sur la
partie euredec et la c'est une
centrale de coachat avec nos nos nos
amis de
rêvé groupe de distribution allemand
avec lequel nous négocions en commun euh
euh sur des prix de marchandises au
niveau européenne euh ce n'est pas une
question de détournement de loi ou quoi
que ce soit euh ce sont des pratiques
qui sont fait dans d'autres métiers ça
impressionne personne chez Airbus ça
impressionne personne chez dans la
téléphonie çaimessionne partout mais ça
devrait impressionner dans la
distribution donc je suis effectivement
je je ne vais pas commenter des
commentaires qui sont faits par des
industriels qui iraient à Bruxelles à
Madrid ou ailleurs mais euh nous
aujourd'hui on s'est mis d'accord avec
rêv depuis des années et on achète en
commun non pas pour non pas pour
détourner une loi quelconque mais pour
avoir le poids suffisant face à des
industriels dont je vous rappelle la
taille euh et qui sont largement plus
importants que nous dans un pays comme
la France j'écoutais euh l'autre jour je
lisais un article de du eu du président
France d'Unilever euh la France est 8e
pays univever au monde euh on est un des
moins rentables d'ailleurs il y a tout
un mais je vous invite à le lire c'est
très intéressant il a et il a dit lui
aussi à peu près ce qu'on vient de dire
euh en creux
euh donc donc voilà je je je je vois pas
pourquoi monosil vous avez encore une
minutes souhaitez-vous poser des
questions additionnelles ou je
souhaiterais que Dominique chelcher et
Alexandre Bompard répondent à la même
question
monsieur chelcha absolument donc nous
concernant il s'agit de la structure
éest qui est une comment dire
organisation d'achat effectivement
européenne où nous achetons en commun
avec notre partenaire européen qui
s'appelle edek qui est le leader en
Allemagne pourquoi nous faisons cela
parce que nous voyons bien que avec un
certain nombre de très grands
industriels puisque ça ne concerne que
les très grands industriels nous sommes
en en difficulté de de de discussion je
précise que l'adhésion à notre
dispositif est totalement volontaire
c'est-à-dire que l'industriel qui ne
veut pas venir et certains nous le
disent et ben ne vient pas on l'a
proposé on le propose à 44 grands
industriels essentiellement
multinationaux et donc c'est une
adhésion volontaire et donc ceux qui ne
voudront pas aller dedans n'iront pas il
n'y a absolument pas pour nous de
comment dire de de volonté aucune
de détourner la fiscalité quoi que ce
soit voilà merci beaucoup on arrive au
terme des 4 minutes je vous propose
éventuellement si on n'a pas totalement
répondu vous répondrez à la toute fin
vous pourrez relancer tout à l'heure
avec les questions individuelles je vous
propose de passer à présent à grégore de
fournace pour le groupe rassem national
c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président je je
voulais dire qu'à la question qui était
posée précédemment nous ne sommes pour
notre part pas du tout satisfaits des
des réponses mais je croisis que la loi
des croaille avait résolu le problème
mais visiblement ça n'a pas été le le
cas de de pour ces centrales d'achat à
l'étranger qui détourne la loi française
merci Monsieur donc le président pour
cette prise de parole je voudrais donc
comme il se doit remercier les
intervenants de cette table ronde de
leur présence et leur contribution débat
public tout particulièrement sur le
sujet de l'inflation qui est un drame
pour bon nombre de familles françaises
frappé le plein fouet par la hausse des
prix en effet une étude récente a
démontré que près d'un Français sur deux
se résigné à sauter des repas tant la
vie était devenue cherre face à cette
situation les Français sont spectateurs
d'un gouvernement impuissant qui a
promis pendant des mois un chèque
alimentaire qui n'est jamais venu ou
assister au V admonestation de Bruno
Leem rester sans résultat pas plus tard
que hier soir nous avons vu cette nous
avons vu cette idée particulièrement
contestable de la vente à perte des des
carburants rejeté par la grande
distribution ce qui n'a pas manqué de
nous sidérer tant nous paraissait tant
nous paraî surréaliste pardon que la
première ministre ait pu formuler cette
idée sans visiblement demander leur avis
aux principaux
intéressés dans cette période difficile
certains d'entre vous patrons de la
grande distribution ont cru bon
d'endosser le costume de chevalier blanc
du pouvoir d'achat avec ce talent si
particulier de réussir à faire croire
que les coupables se trouvaient partout
sauf parmi vous
nous ne contestons évidemment pas que
les industriels de l'agroalimentaire
portent aussi une une part de
responsabilité et mon collègue Nicolas
maisonet aura l'occasion d'interpeller
ses représentants tout à l'heure mais
nous nous interrogeons tout de même
sérieusement sur le rôle de la grande
distribution et sur ses marges il ne
s'agit évidemment pas de mettre tout le
monde à la même enseigne si certains
d'entre vous très rares jouent le jeu il
est cependant extrêmement difficile de
croire à certains discours tenus par
l'un ou l'autre d'entre vous pour
s'exonérer de vos responsabilité la
grande distribution porte une
responsabilité responsabilité dans cette
inflation il est en effet prouvé que
depuis la loi égalime 1 et la mise en
place de cette mesure contestable du SRP
+ 10 vous avez augmenté vos marges de
600 millions d'euros par an selon un
rapport sénatorial ces 600 millions
d'euros ont été pris dans la poche des
Français sont venus alourdir le coût de
leur vie je donc une seule
question à Leclerc ou Carrefour par
exemple au lieu de rejeter la faute sur
les autres et de vous exonérer de vos de
votre part de responsabilité
comptez-vous assumer le rôle que vous
jouez aussi dans cette inflation et rend
au français ces 600 millions d'euros
merci donc monsieur bonpar monsieur
Michot qui souhaite commencer monsieur
bonpar c'est à vous monsieur le député
merci moi j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que je suis le seul qui est côté
comme je suis côté je je publie des
données qui sont auditables certifiées
et qui et que vous pouvez regarder vous
vous vous essayerez de trouver les 600
millions de marges supplémentaires
malheureusement ils n'y sont pas je
voudrais juste vous rappeler une ou deux
réalités parce que les chiffres sont
quand même importants dans un secteur
d'activité comme le nôtre une entreprise
comme Carrefour ça c'est une donnée
publié fait en France exactement 2,1 %
de marge 2,1 % de marge c'est mais
malheureusement non ça ne peut pas être
faux parce que ça c'est une donnée
publiée elle est présente partout vous
la retrouverez partout évidemment c'est
un rapport de 1 à 5 avec les industriels
là n'est pas d'envoyer la la
responsabilité aux industriels mais la
distribution c'est un secteur de petite
marge mes camarades ne publient pas mais
je suis certain qu'ils sont dans des
ordres de de de de de à peu près
équivalents nous ne voulons pas en c'est
ni le rôle d'une ONG ni celui de
chevalier ban en revanche notre rôle
parce que c'est notre vocation chers
monsieur parce que nous accueillons tous
les jours des millions de clients c'est
de les accompagner dans cette crise on
ne le fait pas parce que nous sommes une
ong on le fait parce que le rôle de la
distribution nous sommes concurrents
vous savez tout au long de la journée là
aujourd'hui nous sommes face à vous
comme la grande distribution mais nous
sommes concurrents toute la journée
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
concurrent attirer des clients
développer des part de marché se
développer soi-même investir transformer
on le fait en étant tous les jours au
côté nos clients et depuis 2 ans la
grande distribution porte une
responsabilité sur certains sujets bien
sûr comme tous les secteurs d'activité
nous ne sommes pas exemp de critique en
revanche depuis 2 ans c'est très
difficile de ne pas reconnaître que la
grande distribution parfois l'initiative
du gouvernement d'ailleurs a été présent
dans beaucoup de dispositifs des paniers
des opérations a prisoutant ou en
développant des marques propres c'est ça
notre métierci merci beaucoup monsieur
président directeur général je vous
propose de passer à présent à Madame
Mathilde ignier pour le groupe la France
insoumise c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président oui
messieur monsieur le Président juste
peut-être que à l'avenir on devrait
respecter la parité pour les auditions
prochaines je ferme la parenthèse
attendez juste histoire de je vous
remets à zéro le compteur madame vous
inquiétez pas juste préciser que je ne
maîtrise pas les commex des des des
personnes que nous recevons j'ai pris un
critère comme je dis tout à l'heure qui
est très objectif qui est la part de
marché et j'ai pris les quatre plus gros
acteurs en fonction de leur part de
marché et et voilà je ne je ce n'est pas
moi qui
nomme la direction et les présidents de
ces différents groupes voilà madame iier
je repars à zéro sur le fond peut-être
allez-y merci monsieur le Président donc
oui depuis 2 ans l'inflation alimentaire
touche les Françaises et les Français
qui sont déjà fragilisé et papérisé par
des décennies
d'austérité les 37 produits du quotidien
du g de course coûte 20 € de plus au
mois d'août 2023 qu'un an auparavant
conséquence les Françaises et les
Français sont de plus en plus à se
priver de nourriture on a un une
personne sur 6 qui dit être contrainte
de se priver de nourriture on a l'écrit
d'alerte des association qui se
multiplie les restos du cœur la Croix
Rouge 8 millions de Français qui sont de
personnes qui sont contraintes de de
recourir aux association d'aide
alimentaire alors je trouve que dans la
7e puissance mondiale et bien on ne peut
pas accepter cette cette situation et
visiblement continuer à demander à
supplier les entreprises de faire un
effort sans aucune obligation d'agir ben
ça marche pas euh donc c'est vrai que
depuis tout à l'heure vous mettez en
cause les industriels mais vous n'êtes
pas sans reste parce que les les groupes
de de les les groupes de distribution
que vous représentez ont multiplié des
déclarations affirmant que la grande
distribution avait tout fait pour
réduire l'inflation et pourtant si vos
marges n'ont pas explosé comme celles
des industrielles que nous allons
interroger tout à l'heure elles n'ont
pas baisser pour autant pire encore on
constate que vos marges ont surtout
augmenté sur les produits où les
industriels n'ont pas considérablement
augmenté les leurs si on prend par
exemple les pattes on on une
augmentation de 6,6 % de marge pour
l'industrie et 57 % pour la grande
distribution donc sans compter que les
consommateurs se sont reportés
massivement sur les marques
distributeurs où vos marges sont les
plus importantes en gros si les gens ils
se serrent la ceinture c'est en grande
partie pour augmenter vos profits euh
par exemple monsieur monsieur bonpard
Carrefour affiche une augmentation de
8,3 % de revenus dans l'alimentaire au
premier trimestre de cette année vous
avez versé 2,1 milliard de dividendes
àos vos actionnaires et pourtant vous
comptez supprimer 900 emplois en France
donc comment justifiez-vous cette
décision et que comptez-vous mettre en
place pour permettre à nos concitoyens
et concitoyennes de vraiment retrouver
des prises abordables on a Monsieur le
le ministre Bruno Le ma qui entend
réouvrir les négociations commerciales
mais cela ne vous oblige en rien encore
une fois le gouvernement va demander
sans contraindre vous ou les industriels
à stopper les profits sur le dos des
consommateurs donc peut-on vraiment
attendre de vous un engagement à réduire
vos marges et enfin participer à
l'effort de solidarité je vous remercie
je vous remercie qui souhaite répondre
il reste une minute 30 mon Paris merci
beaucoup merci
madame vous avez évoqué le le chiffre
d'affaires qui comme vous le savez n'est
pas la rentabilité le chiffre d'affaires
il il est évidemment renforcé par
l'inflation hein quand vous avez de
l'inflation vous avez un chiffre
d'affaires qui croit et vous avez des
coûts qui croissent aussi ce qui fait
que la marge opérationnelle est
constante après comment elle se réparti
le la valeur ajoutée une très grande
partie chez nous 60 % vient rémunérer
les salariés à travers les dispositifs
de rémunération quotidiennees les primes
les intéressements et les primes
exceptionnelles 20 % vient rémunérer
vient pour investir 15 % pour payer des
impôts 10 % pour les dividendes et le
achat des actions qui sont la façon de
érer les actionnaires et les
investisseurs qui nous accompagnent dans
le développement de l'entreprise une
entreprise ça a besoin d'actionnaire ça
a besoin d'investisseurs ça besoin de
gens qui croient en l'entreprise et ça
représente 10 % de la valeur ajoutée du
Groupe sert à ça et 90 % rémunération
des salariés investissement impôt madame
comme il reste 30 secondes avez-vous
quelque chose de plus à dire non et bien
je vous propose à ce moment-là de passer
à notre prochain orateur de groupe il
s'agit de Monsieur Julien div pour le
groupe les républicains c'est c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président merci
messieur pour vos propos votre rôle est
de défendre bien sûr vos activités vos
entreprises les indépendants que vous
représentez lorsque c'est le cas les
salariés les actionnaires lorsqu'il y en
a notre rôle et de défendre protéger les
concitoyens les consommateurs les
agriculteurs les industriels les
entreprises indépendants commerçantes
qui sont dans No territoire et qui ont
des emplois et donc les emplois c'est
aussi la raison qui explique pourquoi
depuis 2017 le législateur avec des
différences d'avis de vision et autres
peu importe à légiférer autant 2017 les
états généraux de l'alimentation on se
rappelle de ces grandes mes qui
permettait justement pour la première
fois de mettre autour de la table les
trois acteurs concernés aussi bien
transformateur producteur que
distributeur euh les différentes lois
qui interviennent jusque récemment la
loi des croisailles euh et on voit bien
qu'on se retrouve à chaque fois au
milieu du gay avec des solutions qui qui
ne satisfassent pas euh ni consommateur
ni industriel ni producteur ni euh ni
distributeur moi je vous pose une
question simple puisque là nous avons
une loi d'exception qui va être une
parenthèse je crois qu'il faut une loi
de réaction et éviter de toujours
refaire la législation pensez-vous je
mets un pavier dans la marre hein mais
c'est pour ouvrir le débat aussi
pensez-vous et je prends la balle au bon
du propos de Monsieur Cotillard qu'il
faille purement et simplement supprimer
une date
butoire est-ce que cette question de la
date butoire doit être mise en cause
tout en gardant et je le précise des
gardes de fous qui protègent la matière
première agricole de nos exploitants et
qui permettent de de protéger les
petites PME c'est un vrai débat que nous
devons avoir c'est un changement de
paradigme c'est une vraie question qu'on
doit se poser j'aimerais avoir votre
réaction sur le srp+ 10 parce que
personnellement moi j suis attaché au
titre du ruissellement qu'il y a dans
les fermes de France mais c'est vrai que
ça peut poser questions sur certains
produits alimentaires et là aussi
j'aimerais que vous puissiez vous-même
vous exprimer sur la question et enfin
la dernière question que que que j'ai
elle s'adresse à Monsieur Michot moi je
ne rette pas que Monsieur Lecler ne soit
pas là vous êtes co-président euh du
groupe Leclerc comme Monsieur micheldard
Leclerc donc vous êtes solidaire
coresponsable des des des prises de
parole et j'aimerais que vous puissiez
répéter les propos qu'il a tenu chez
Madame mabrook devant la représentation
nationale et je vais le citer il n'y a
pas unanimité au gouvernement il n'y a
pas unanimité chez chez les
parlementaires il n'y a pas unanimité au
sein des parlementaires du groupe
majoritaire il y a des gens qui sont
pour l'inflation il y a des gens qui ont
des intérêts financiers qui possèdent
des actions d'entreprise et qui ont
besoin de cette inflation qui veulent
cette inflation pouvez-vous réitérer ces
propos monsieur Michot et pouvez-vous
nous donner à nous députés puisque nous
avons besoin de ces éléments puisque
s'il y a des gens qui ont besoin de
cette inflation pouvez nous dire et nous
donner les arguments qui expliquent ces
allégations je vous remercie monsieur
Michot bien évidemment je vais réitérer
la parole de de Michel et que je partage
complètement sur le sur le sujet on a
aujourd'hui une petite musique depuis
des lustres enfin des lustres quelques
quelques mois ou quelques petites années
que
l'inflation n'est pas obligatoirement
euh limite tout le monde il faut pas se
il faut pas se voiler la face le monde
financier les banques
euh les taxes que ça
génère compenser certainement si elle
est maîtrisée parce qu' on parle pas du
problème de l'inflation elle-même mais
de la maîtrise de l'inflation là
aujourd'hui ce qui pose un problème
c'est que l'inflation n'a pas du tout
été maîtrisée elle était certainement
pas ma able je jette la pierre à
personne elle a peut-être été aussi liée
à une récupération de déflation des
années précédente je sais pas je je suis
pas dans la tête de de ceux qui sont qui
sont à la à la manœuvre dans ces chosesl
mais une chose est certaine c'est qu'on
ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui le
contraire et je le pense réellement que
2 à 3 %
d'inflation n'est pas
obligatoirement une tâche dans le
tableau pour beaucoup oup d'acteurs et
je mettrai c'est tout alésidci il y
avait deux autres questions
passionnantes monsieur div mais comme on
est arrivé au bout des 4 minutes je vous
propose de répondre globalement à la fin
de des questions individuelles je vous
propose de passer tout de suite à
Monsieur Richard Ramos pour le groupe
démocrate c'est à vous oui messieur moi
je suis très content parce que vous êtes
tous d'accord c'est que vous tirez la
Bour sur le dos du Pr des prix bas mais
quand vous êtes tous ensemble vous êtes
tous d'accord donc ça c'est vachement
bien alors moi ce que je voudrais savoir
c'est quand certains industriels grugent
le consommateur notamment par la
scflation on cache l'emballage pourquoi
vous mettez pas d'accord là pour le coup
pour les sortir de tous vos rayons donc
comment on voit que vous êtes toujours
d'accord face à nous tous ensemble et
bien là vous mettez d'accord et vous les
Soré donc au moins ça servirait à ça
ensuite je reprends ce que disait
monsieur descroill sur la loi des
scrosilles moi j'ai Bagaré contre les
pénalités logistiques moi je voudrais
que chacun d'entre vous individuellement
me dise non nous ne facturons plus des
pénalités logistiques qui sont qui ne
sont pas justifié et je vous présenterai
à certains d'entre vous les factures et
je veux que vous me disiez devant la
représentation nationale oui nous
respectons la loi nous ne facturons pas
des pénalités logistiques qui n'existent
pas voilà ça c'est ça qui est très
important et puis encore une fois vous
parliez d'erbus monsieur chez Leclerc en
étant l'Europe mais 97 18 % de votre
chiffre d'affaires il est fait en France
donc qu'avez-vous besoin d'aller créer
des filiales à l'étranger
je je regrette que Carrefour est pris
cette envie d'aller apprendre l'espagnol
je dirais on a aujourd'hui c'est pas que
les multinationales on a des PME qui qui
des ETI qui sont qui sont qui sont dans
ces affaires là et donc là aussi c'est
très important et puis arrêtez pardon de
parler des industriels il y a les
multinationales mais la France est
couverte de PME et de TI et donc ceux
arrêtez de les mettre dans le même sac
que les autres parce que cela à force de
vouloir ce que vous faites Michel
éedouard Leclerc vous avez gagné avec
vos Leclerc 1 % et demi de part de
marché sur sur l'inflation pourquoi
parce que vous avez tapé du prix taper
du prix taper du prix c'est quoi c'était
hier avoir des industriels qui trichent
sur les emballage c'est demain des
recettes qui vont changer on va être
très attentif et on aura besoin de VOUS
également pour nous dire queil y a des
gens qui trichent parce qu'ils mettent
plus de gras plus de sucre plus de sel
pour être moins cher alors je vous le
dis on va vous surveiller sur la loi des
scrusailles parce que j'ai vu des choses
qui ne sont malhonnêtes est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire devant la
représentation nationale chacun d'entre
vous que sur les pénalités logistiques
vous respecterez la loi alors sur cette
question qui souhaite répondre monsieur
bonpard monsieur
chelchard monsieur
chelchard sur la question des pénalités
logistiques c'est vraiment un point que
j'ai vérifié encore avant de venir mais
écoutez moi je vous dis que on fait tout
pour respecter la loi et on la respecte
et ce sont des montants qui ont
fortement diminuer ces dernières années
parce que la loi a évolué pour moi c'est
c'est allé dans le dans le bon sens et
et il faut la respecter il faut la
respecter après vous avez dit Monsieur
le Député quelque chose d'extrêmement
important et que j'ai pas eu l'occasion
de dire jusqu'à présent oui vous avez
raison faut distinguer absolument les
très grands industriels et pour nous ils
sont une poignée je CIT un chiffre de 44
tout à l'heure et l'immense majorité des
autres producteurs qui sont des PME et
des ETI où on essaie de traiter les
choses avec beaucoup de discernement en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on s'est vertu de
faire et donc il faudrait pas que la
discussion de ce matin absolument se
résume par que un sujet de grands
industriels pensons PME nous sommes les
premiers à le dire chez systè monsieur
bonpard vous aviez levé la main non mais
même chose peut-être juste ça permet de
faire un lien avec la la la question du
de Monsieur le Député descroosaill nous
nous sommes européens on est premier
acteur en Europe et je n'achète avec
personne d'autre Carrefour achète avec
Carrefour ce ce qui est pas très
exceptionnel on a donc juste un bureau
d'achat quatre grandes multinationales
aujourd'hui sont concerné par ce bureau
d'achat aucune PME aucune PMI n'y
viendra jamais ce qu'on achète en France
on continuera à l'acheter en France ça a
vocation à acheter à partir de Madrid
Carrefour achetant avec Carrefour pour
une vingtaine ou une trentaine peut-être
de grandes multinationales
internationales qui sont elles aussi
européennes pour les pénalités
logistiques nous respectons aussi la loi
je vous remercie nous sommes arrivver au
terme des 4 minutes je vous propose de
passer à Monsieur Dominique potier pour
le groupe socialiste c'est à
[Musique]
vous merci monsieur le Président je
voulais en amont de cette table ronde
des deux tbles rondes dénoncer
clairement le parti prix de l'absence
béante des représentants de la
production alors qu'on parle de la
construction des prix de la lutte contre
l'inflation nous sommes à l'issue d'un
cycle qui a commencé avec sapin 2 égalim
1 égalim 2 égalim 3 et la loi qui se
prépare pour être le détricotage des
efforts patients insatisfaisants mais
méritoires pour essayer de construire
des prix justes tout au long des chaînes
de production alors moi jeis vous
demander un exercice d'honnêteté puisque
c'est c'est ce que vous devez à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui la
première question porte sur la réalité
des marches 2,1 pour Carrefour
Entreprise côté tout le monde sait qu'il
y a consolidation avec des filiales qui
a de l'optimisation fiscale notamment
par le vecteur de l'immobilier est-ce
que nous pouvons enfin nous dire la
vérité en matière de marge en
consolidant l'ensemble des sociétés
compris les prestations annexes connexes
qui constituent les marges réelles de la
grande distribution nous avons ce devoir
d'honnêé je crois entre nous depuis 2
ans quels sont les efforts réels que
vous avez fait en matière de réduction
des écarts de salaires qui sont
particulièrement indécents dans votre
secteur et de la rémunération du capital
afin de contribuer à l'effort du pouvoir
d'achat du pouvoir de vivre de nos
concitoyens enfin en matière de la loi
de loi descrosaill la volonté d'une
souveraineté nationale dans la
définition des règles du jeu visait à
condamner toutes les plateformes situées
à l'étranger qui ne respectaient pas la
loi française comment pourquoi et et
comment entendez-vous respecter cette
loi contre contrairement aux allégations
qui ont été faites sur les plateformes
d'achat
international que vous avez établi à
l'étranger aujourd'hui respectez-vous la
loi ui ou non en la matière je vous
remercie je je vais essayer de répondre
sur la rité des marges nous on a fait le
choix depuis 3 ans d'investir dans le
commerce c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
il y a une guerre commerciale entre nous
et nous on fait le pari de se dire si on
propose des prix attractifs aux
consommateurs ils viendront chez nous
donc la réalité chez Intermarché les
chiffres ont été envoyés à berc c'est
une baisse de marge de 03 points mais la
réalité c'est que la masse de marge en
valeur est effectivement plus importante
puisque nous recrutons des nouveaux
consommateurs et les gens viennent chez
nous sur la question des salaires je
peux pas m'exprimer sur la réalité de ce
qui se passe en point de vente par
contre je peux le faire pour les 25000
salariés qui sont ou en logistique ou
dans nos outils de production puisque on
a nos propres usines la réalité c'est
desnégo entre 5 à 6 % 2 années de suite
donc on avait la volonté vous pourrez le
vérifier d'accompagner l'inflation et
donc on est à plus de 10 % sur nos outil
industriel et sur nos bases logistiques
quant à la question sur la centrale
d'achat je suit l'exception puisque
Intermarché n'a pas aujourd'hui de
centrale d'achat ni buying office donc
on est bien sur un territoire français
dans le drit français merci Monsieur
potier il vous reste une minute ou
quelqu'un d'autre
souhaitait sur la r desmarche bien
évidemment je je je je ne peux que
confirmer ce chiffre en ce qui nous
concerne en tout cas parce que c'est la
moyenne des des des des chiffres des
magasins France alors ça reste une
moyenne bien évidemment vous devz avoir
des écarts des écarts types mais qui ne
sont pas si importants que ça mais en
tout cas la moyenne c'est celle-ci
celle-là je vous la confirme euh sur les
écarts de salaires je je vais dire comme
comme Thierry Cotillard je je vais pas
pouvoir m'engager devant la
représentation nationale en disant voilà
les salaires chez Leclerc ça a été temps
mais de ce que j'en entends en tout cas
on a fait les Hauses de salaires qui
sucite entre 8 et 10 % pour l'ensemble
des salariés euh mais je le je je met je
je là aussi vous pourrez trouver ici et
là peut-être des écarts qui ne sont pas
qui ne confirment pas ce que je suis en
train de dire et puis pour revenir sur
la loi de décrois bien évidemment on
respectera les règles de l'article 1 si
je ne m'abuse et si mes souvenirs sont
bons vous me parlez de l'article 1 euh
en fonction de de de de ce que cet
article pourra donner merci beaucoupoup
merci beaucoup je vous propose somes
arrivé au terme des 4 minutes je vous
propose de passer à Monsieur Thierry
Benoît pour le groupe horizon c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président euh
quelques centrales d'achat on a là
l'illustration parfaite de ce qu'est la
concentration de la distribution dans
notre pays parce que vous êtes quatre
grands de la distribution en France face
à vous 75 multinationales et 17000
environ TPE et PME et ce qui pose
problème finalement est-ce que ça n'est
pas la concentration c'est-à-dire vous
les quatre grandes de la distribution et
les 75 multinationales puisqueen fait
avec les 17000 TPE et PME si j'ai bien
compris les choses se passent bien et
nous avons tout intérêt nous à veiller à
préserver ces 17000 entreprises
agroalimentaires parce que c'est une des
spécificités de la France ça regroupe
460000 emplois et en amont il y a 400000
producteurs première question la
concentration de la distribution est-ce
que ça n'est pas tout simplement la
structuration du qu'il faut revoir
c'est-à-dire inverser la logique des
politiques publiques telles qu'elles
sont faites depuis 50 ans qui donnent la
partbelle à la grande distribution avec
toutes les lois qui ont été votées
globalement queles que soient les lois
galant
sapin Royer LME égalim 1 2 et j'en passe
et vous arrivez finalement à vous
adapter deuxième question comment se
fait-il que pour un agriculteur on est
capable de lui garantir un contrat de
rachat de l'énergie s'il produit de l'
énergie à partir de panneaux
photovoltaïque ou de méthanisation on
sait lui garantir un contrat sur
quelques années alors que sur les
denrées alimentaires et les produits
agricoles qu'il produit on n'est pas
fichu capable de lui garantir un contrat
sur de 3 ans 3ème point les négociations
commerciales j'ai présidé une commission
d'enquête sur les négociations
commerciales pourquoi ne pas arrêter de
délocaliser les négociations commercial
à l'extérieur de la France lorsque ça
concerne les marchés français 4è
la question du carburant grâce à égalim
on est allé sur une logique de
construction des prix marche en avant
qui tient compte des coûts de production
et nous sommes arrivés à l'apogé avec la
loi de notre collègue descroosailles qui
finalement a sanctuarisé la non
négociabilité des matières premières
agricoles est-ce que avec la vente à
perte du carburant tel qu'elle se
profile pour les mois à venir est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de casser et
d'inverser cette dynamique dernier point
vous êtes les papes de la communication
la grande distribution c'est 3 milliards
de publicité c'est 20 % de la publicité
en France arrive derrière vous 9 % c'est
la part des banques donc vous avez la
plus grande responsabilité vis-à-vis du
consommateur non pas pour qu'il consomme
plus mais pour qu'il achète mieux et
notamment l'éduquer à la qualité de
l'alimentation et à une meilleure
nutrition merci beaucoup alors en une
minute qui souhaite relever le challenge
monsieur chelcher c'est à
vous monsieur le député euh premier
point sur euh les contrats vous dites
pourquoi vous ne signez pas des contrats
de longue durée mais nous le faisons
nous le faisons par exemple pour la
production de notre marque u euh tous
les produits frais à la marque u font
l'objet euh de contrat ce qu'on appelle
triparti vous avez autour de la table
une coopérative nous-même un
transformateur euh au plus long nous
signons des contrats sur 5 ans donc nous
savons le faire et nous trou trouvons
très inspirant ce que nous arrivons à
faire sur justement les Mar
distributeurs et ça devrait rejaillir et
donc la question de tout à l'heure qui
était mais est-ce qu'il faut pas
discuter toute l'année ben c'est ce que
nous faisons sur la marque distributeur
et ce que moi j'appelle de longuees date
à faire sur les autres industriels pour
aussi mettre plus
d'apaisement arrêter de délocaliser les
négociations en dehors de de de de la
France encore une fois quand un panier
vendu sang en en moyenne au niveau
européen il est vendu 115 en France il
est vendu 95 en Espagne le but de ces
discussions là elles sont aussi pour
apporter du pouvoir d'achat au français
merci beaucoup monsieur chur je vous
propose de passer à monsieur le
président André chassig pour le groupe
GDR c'est à
VOUS bonjour première question lequel
des quatre papes que vous êtes
pensez-vous qu'il faudrait béatifier
voir canoniser en premier pour son du
sacrifice et les miracles de son action
qui permet à la fois qui permet à la
fois de satisfaire les consommateurs en
souffrance les revendications de leurs
salariés et bien évidemment la
gourmandise des actionnaires deè
question avez-vous définitivement
abandonner certaines pratiques que nous
combattons depuis des décennies bon il y
a bien sûr la réduction de la quantité
des emballages pour pour masquer les
augmentations mais des pratiques
notamment dans les contacts directs avec
vos fournisseurs locaux marge arrière ça
plus transfert vers les fournisseurs de
fausses animations qui sont des emplois
déguisés ça n'existe plus sanction
abusive de fournisseurs par des
pénalités ou dé férancement de produits
sans doute que ça n'existe plus aussi et
dernière question je sais pas à qui je
peux la poser au 4 sur quel produit vous
pensez compenser la vente à perte du
carburant est-ce que c'est en vous
fournissant ailleurs à l'étranger par
exemple alors quel est le PAP qui
souhaite répondre en
premier monsieur bonpard je n'ai pas le
malheureusement je je ne serais
pas je ne peux pas devenir PAP cette
année en revanche vous avez très bien
posé la question parce que vous avez dit
quoi c'est quoi notre métier vous l'avez
parfaitement dit il y a plein de parties
prenant les consommateurs pardonnez-nous
vous pouvez penser que nous ne sommes
pas là pour les défendre nous sommes là
pour les défendre parce que c'est notre
métier notre métier c'est de conquérir
des clients moi à la fin de la semaine
quel est le vecteur d'une bonne semaine
c'est quand j'ai des clients satisfaits
fidèles qui reviennent et que je gagne
des partarts de marché sur mes petits
camarades c'est ça mon métier et je le
fais pas si je le trompe je le fais pas
si j'augmente les prix je le fais quand
je le fais bien quand je tiens bien mes
magasins quand j'ai une bonne marque
propre quand les prix sont bas quand les
opérations commerciales sont bonnes
c'est mon métier je ne le fais pas parce
que je veux être pape ou que vous me
remerciez c'est mon métier vous avez
deuxième partie prenante les salariés
vous avez tout à fait raison nous sommes
aussi là pour avoir des salariés qui
sont heureux d'être chez nous qui sont
fidèles qui bénéficient de l'ascenseur
social 3ème partie prenante vous avez
raison pour ce qui me concerne c'est
d'autres organisations pour les
indépendants les actionnaires et les
investisseurs j'en ai besoin aussi parce
que j'ai besoin qu'ils investissent dans
l'entreprise carrefour pour me
développer et rester un des premiers
acteur au monde c'est toutes ces parties
prenantes que je dois essayer de
satisfaire ça fait pas de moi le PAP pas
du tout je ne suis pas une ONG pas du
tout mais c'est ma responsabilité c'est
de satisfaire l'ensemble de ces parties
prenantes après euh sur la la la vente à
perte monsieur le le le député vous avez
raison le le principe de la revente à
perte c'est un principe très important
c'est un principe très important du
commerce depuis
1963 comme vous le savez nous n'avons
pas le droit de revendre à perte c'est
un principe important il ne faut
d'ailleurs pas trop ouvrir cette boîte
de pendor là au risque de fragiliser à
la fois l'équilibre des filières et de
fragiliser l'équité territoriale entre
les consommateurs donc en ce qui nous
concerne nous groupe Carrefour nous
puisque nous ne pouvons pas nous
concerter vous le savez nous n'avons pas
vocation et nous n'avons pas nous ne
vendrons pas à perte nous continuerons à
faire des opérations à PROUANT parce que
nous ne pouvons pas vendre à Pertre
parce que si je me mets à vendre à perte
de l'essence je fragilise l'ensemble de
l'équilibre que je vient de vous décrire
donc nous continuerons à nous battre
avec des opérations à prix cûant mais
notre modèle ne nous permet pas de
vendre à perte comme il reste 30
secondes est-ce que le président chassen
souhaitait rajouter quelque chose j'ai
pas tout àit attend bon j'é pour moi oui
sur les les les pratiques là ces
fameuses pratiques qui sont disant ont
disparu et qui semblent-ils sont mis en
œuvre par des achats de proximité sur
les territoires avec des fournisseurs
qui sont à proximité des des magasins
comment ça se passe malheureusement il
nous reste pas de temps sur les 4
minutes mais vous pourrez répondre tout
à
l'heure vous pourrez répondre tout à
l'heure à la toute fin des questions
individuelles merci cher Président
chassigne je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Paul Molac pour le groupe Yot
c'est oui merci monsieur le Président
donc
messieurs j'ai entendu des choses sur la
loi des croosailles ce que je peux dire
quand même c'est que je reviens du Space
à Rennes et ça a permis quand même au
niveau des agriculteurs de donner un peu
d'air parce qu'on a eu un moment donné
où la concurrence et les prix agricoles
faisaent que de toute façon on
détruisait des fermes et finalement on
détruisait l'outil de travail
directement donc je crois que c'est
c'est important à souligner même si tout
n'est pas parfait bien sûr loin de là
mais ça a quand même donné un petit peu
d'air sans doute avec d'autres d'autres
facteurs une question s'il y a pas de
date butoire quand est-ce qu'on termine
les négociations puisque j'ai entendu
qu'il fallait pas de date butoire donc
c'est un peu compliqué parce que si à un
moment donné vous dites pas bon voilà on
acte des des prix qui augmentent ou qui
baissent mais peu importe mais s'il y a
pas de date butoire quand est-ce qu'on
les acte cette première chose la
deuxième qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
contrats tripartites puisque vous parlez
des des grands industriels alors on a
quand même souligné qu'effectivement on
a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de PME et
de TI dans dans l'agroalimentaire qui
font et c'est pour ça qu'on a aussi un
panel un choix qui est quand même très
important la gastronomie c'est quelque
chose donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ces contrats
tripartites sur la loi sur le projet de
loiy Monsieur cotien ouais très bien sur
le projet de loi de crousa il y a
plusieurs points le le fait de pouvoir
renégocier tout au long de l'année on
pense que c'est inévitable parce qu'on
va au devant d'une volatilité qui sera
de plus en plus forte notamment sur des
matières premières agricooles qui vont
souffrir des aléas climatiques et donc
le Français a bien compris que quand ça
hausse il comprend les hausses mais il a
surtout compris que il ne comprend pas
par contte que quand ça baisse ça baisse
pas donc évidemment la demande qu'on a
de pouvoir renégocier tout au long de
l'année comme nos confrères portugais
espagnol nous sommes tout àfait légitime
avancer la négociation puisque c'est
dans le projet de loi on vous dit oui si
on a la garantie c'est pas pour passer
des hausses mais plutôt évidemment
passer des baisses et je vais ouvrir une
parenthèse puisqu'on a pu échanger avec
le député de creusaille le vrai sujet
qu'on a et sur lequel on voudrait que
vous puissiez reeréfléchir à la question
c'est le sujet des 34 % concernant les
promotions du DPH nous au niveau de
l'enseignne Intermarché c'est pas loin
de 70 millions d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat qu'on redonne grâce à ces
promotions la moyenne des promotions sur
le DPH c'est 50 % donc les limité à 34 %
on trouve que ça n'est pas dans dans le
sens logique des choses à un moment où
il y a une pression sur le pouvoir
d'achat et donc dans l'ensemble de la
loi de croille on est vraiment favorable
à la recondition des galimes parce que
comme vous le dites alors moi je suis
pas allé au Space mais je suis allé au
centre d'agriculture et ça se détend
c'estàdire quand vous voyez Thierry
rockfeuille il vous dit quand même le
lait on en vit mieux et cetera et on a
cette responsabilité collective de pas
toucher à ça donc merci au députés de
proposer ça mais réellement sur le le
DPH il y a une incompréhension qui sera
difficile à comprendre d'autant qu'il y
a un sujet de distorsion de concurrence
vous connaissez action vous avez tous
entendu parler c'est des concurrents
étrangers alors on accepte la
concurrence mais ils achètent aux
Pays-Bas et ils achètent tous les stocks
du nilever de L'Oréal à des prix défoncé
la réalité demain c'est que ce sera pas
sur le prix de fond de rayon qu'on
pourra vendre du shampoing alors que les
Français se restreignent ce serait
évidemment sur la promotion qui pourrait
être dans des proportions à 50 60 % pour
concurrencer ces nouveaux acteurs nous
limiter à 34 % nous met en une situation
vraiment délicate et s'il y a un point
sur lequel vous devez réfléchir mesdames
et messieurs c'est c'est ce point-là au
service du consommateur
il reste 30 secondes est-ce que Monsieur
Mac vous souhaitiez
réagir les dates butoire me dit Monsieur
mollac monsieur chelchard moi je
rajouterai peut-être sur les dates
butoires juste la chose suivante nous
permettre de négocier tout au long de
l'année avec une contractualisation et
un cadre à définir avec les grandes
multinationales mais peut-être garder la
date butoire pour les petites les plus
petites entreprises qu'on veut bien
protéger et et avec lesquels on n pas du
tout les mêmes discussions voilà la
distinction que je ferai
je vous remercie nous sommes arrivés au
terme des orateurs de groupe je vous
propose à présent de passer sur les
questions individuelles comme le temps
est limité ce sera maximum une minute
par question vous connaissez le principe
je vais prendre toutes les questions
messieurs donc à la suite et puis à la
toute fin vous aurez un temps qui reste
donc pour répondre à la totalité de ces
questions on commence tout de suite avec
ma breéjon groupe
Renaissance merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur pour votre présence
aujourd'hui je voudrais revenir
rapidement sur la suppression du seuil
de vente à perte annoncé par la première
ministre monsieur bonpard a déjà répondu
pour sa part je m'adresserai donc à
Monsieur chelcher parce que vous avez
déclaré sur France interre le 12
septembre je vous cite sur le carburant
comme j'achète et je revends je ne peux
pas revendre à perte pour pratiquer le
juste prix je n'en ai pas le droit
contrairement à total energy par exemple
suite à l'annonce de la première
ministre ma question est donc simple
allez-vous vous saisir de cette
possibilité et pourquoi je vous remercie
nous continuons avec Lionel Tivoli
rassemblement national oui monsieur le
Président cher chers collègues les
bienens et les services continuent de
voir leur prix exploser sur forond de
crise énergétique qui perdure du fait
d'une stratégie délibérée des principaux
pays producteurs de pétrole de baisser
leur offre et les compagnies pétrolières
de refaire leur Marg perdu durant la
covid-19 Elizabeth borne a créé la
surprise en annonçant une loi permettant
aux distributeurs de revendre le
carburant à perte 6 mois à partir de
décembre un nouvel outil expliqutant AB
Bery mis à leur disposition pour faire
baisser les prix la possibilité de vente
à perte ne sera pas suivie car elle
n'est économiquement pas tenable
pénaliserit les indépendants mais
surtout elle n'est pas pérenne pour les
Français vous l'avez d'ailleurs tous
refusé alors que le prix du litre flirte
avec les 2 € que pensez-vous d'une
baisse de la TVA de 20 % à 5,5 % sur les
énergies et donc à la pompe pour enfin
agir sur les prêts à la pompe et donc
sur le pouvoir d'achat des Français je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre travers pour Renaissance merci
monsieur le Président l'actualité
économique du moment et l'inflation
notamment sur les produits alimentaires
mérite un débat clair et en toute
transparence et merci d'être là pour
pour le faire les tensions les
contournements les pratiques abusives
semblent demeurer malgré les les outils
législatifs et qui ont été mis en œuvre
depuis un certain nombre d'années et
quand des acteurs des négociations
commerciales se disent trop corsetés
dans un ensemble de règles trop strictes
je souhaite les renvoyer à leur propre
responsabilité pour les agriculteurs ce
qui les protège aujourd'hui c'est la
notion de contrat la non négociabilité
des matières premières agricoles un
meilleur encadrement des des pénalités
logistiques et je souhaite connaître
votre position sur la sanctuarisation
des MPa dans les marques distributeurs
sur lesquelles vous avez une possibilité
d'action à 100 % et venir aussi sur
l'encadrement des promotions dans le DPH
vous souhaitez ne pas être limité à 34 %
de la valeur du produit mais en volume
les promotions représentent moins de 19
% en moyenne alors que la loi prévoit
une limite à 25 %. pourquoi et dans ce
cadre est-ce que vous ne proposez pas
plus de promotion au consommateurs merci
beaucoup Vincent Roland les républicains
merci monsieur le Président il est bien
difficile de comprendre ce qui se passe
vous les acteurs de la grande
distribution et industrielle vous vous
renvoyez la balle sur la baisse des prix
et on assiste à une partie de ping-pong
qui se fait au détriment des
consommateurs mais avant que la fumée
blanche n'apparaisse ne faudrait-il pas
mieux encadrer les communications de la
grande distribution parce qu'il est
fréquent et pour faire mes courses
moi-même je men rends compte que des
offres promotionnelles sont de vraies
fausses offres promotionnelles quand on
regarde le prix du kilo et si on le
compare exactement à d'autres vendeurs
notamment des vendeurs dans le monde
coopératif
agricole Thierry Benoît horizon pour une
relance oui je reviens avec ma première
question de tout à l'heure les peut-on
arrêter de délocaliser les négociations
commerciales hors France lorsqu'il
s'agit du marché et des produit français
mais du marché français ça là c'est la
question du rôle des centrales d'achat
deuxè question puisque les 75
multinationales posent problème vous
pose problème vous nous expliquez que
sur 75 il y en a que 10 qu'on fait une
proposition de nouveaux tarifs tenant
compte qui en a que un sur 10 qui a fait
une proposition de réactualisation des
tarifs pour tenir compte de l'inflation
question est-ce que le législateur doit
adapter le code du commerce qui régit
les règles entre la grande distribution
et ces fameuses 75
multinationales merci beaucoup DIN
signerie merci monsieur le président
ident oui suite à la rencontre des
distributeurs et industriels les 30 et
31 août dernier autour de Bruno Lemire
les partis se sont engagé sur des
baisses ou maintiens de prix sur 5000
produits c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les consommateurs car nos concitoyens
subissent une grosse baisse de pouvoir
d'achat depuis plus plusieurs années
mais quand sera-t-il pour les
producteurs notamment dans le cadre que
le gouvernement autorise la vente à
perte garantis garantissez-vous que les
agriculteurs en particulier ne seront
pas lésés pour que les distributeurs
puissent maintenir le leur marche malgré
les Hauses des prix de l'électricité
notamment j'ai rencontré ce matin avec
plusieurs députés des producteurs
laitiers qui sont particulièrement
inquiier pouvez-vous les
rassurer merci beaucoup à Laurence péel
pour
Renaissance merci monsieur le Président
merci à nos invités d'être venus ce
matin eu ma question s'adresse
particulièrement à le clair mais
finalement elle pourrait aussi être
élargie à tous nos intervenants une
journaliste de complément d'enquête
c'est fait embaucher dans une de vos
centrales régionales elle révèle que le
clerc achèterait plus de marchandises
que nécessaires dans l'objectif de
vendre plus tard au prix fort au
consommateur le surplus acheté au rabais
une pratique qui n'est pas illégale tant
qu'elle ne dépasse pas un certain seuil
25 % de tous les achats au fournisseurs
sur l'année mais qui met les
fournisseurs en difficulté et qui prend
je cite la même journaliste les
consommateurs pour des dindons les
employés interrogés dans l'émission à
vous ne pas toujours respecter ce seuil
alors ma question s'adresse à ça le
clair mais plus largement aux autres que
comptez-vous mettre en place afin de
vérifier que toutes les centrales
appliquent sans exception la loi
rémunère de manière plus juste les
fournisseurs et affiche aux
consommateurs des prix qui reflètent
réellement les prix auxquels Lecler se
fournit je vous remercie Pascal laver
une renaissance merci monsieur le
Président chacun avait eu au début de
vos interventions 5 minutes de propos
liminirees ça fait donc 20 20 minutes de
propos liminires à aucun moment dans vos
bouches dans vos propos je n'ai entendu
le mot d'agriculteur je n'ai entendu le
mot de producteur pourtant j'ai entendu
le mot inflation j'ai entendu le mot
client et j'ai entendu le mot
alimentation je voudrais quand même vous
rappeler à tous les quatre que
l'alimentation ce sont les 400000
agriculteurs qu'il nous reste en France
qu' la qu'il la produise je voudrais
sincèrement parce que je pense que vous
êtes des entreprises européennes des
entreprises françaises des entreprises
citoyennes que vous ayez euh ce respect
citoyen de prendre en cre l'ensemble de
ceux qui vous permettent de vivre à
savoir les producteurs les fournisseurs
de matières premières que constitue
l'alimentation que chacun de vos clients
consomme deux fois par jour nous
légiférons nous continuons à nous
continuerons à légiférer mesdames
messieurs nous continuerons à légiférer
tant que vous ne permettrez pas aux
producteurs de vivre de leur méti merci
beaucoup Monsieur Jean-Pierre viget
LR j le micro merci monsieur le
Président ma question à Monsieur
avec le prix des carburants à 2 € le
litre la situation est devenue vraiment
intenable pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes et vous le savez le projet
de loi qui sera prochainement présenté
prévoit d'autoriser la vente à perte des
carburants ce type d'opération
commerciale est bien évidemment attendu
par les français pour beaucoup d'entre
eux qui n'ont pas d'autre alternative
que la voiture individuelle aussi trois
questions que se passera-t-il à la fin
de cette mesure on va certainement
retrouver les prix initiales de l'État
ne doit pas diminuer la taxation sur la
carburant je le rappelle représente les
2/ers du prix et 3 comment s'assurer que
ces opérations commerciales ne vont pas
pénaliser les 6000 stations
indépendantes qui sont bien souvent
situées en milieu rural je vous remerci
merci beaucoup monsieur grégoard de
fournasse RN
oui merci monsieur le Président je vrais
faire une relance suite à mon
intervention tout à l'heure j'ai bien
entendu
le les bénéfices que réalisait le le
groupe Carrefour et je crois que l'inven
de notre collègue potier a été assez
intéressante et je partage ce qu'il a pu
dire sur le fait queeffectivement il y a
1000 façons de pouvoir camoufler un peu
les les bénéfices d'un groupe moi je
voulais je voulais relancer ma question
et peut-être cette fois-ci à Monsieur
Michot sur la question des du rapport
sénatorial qui dit que le SRP + 10 a
permis à la grande distribution de
dégager 600 millions d'euros de marges
supplémentaires contestez-vous euh ce
rapport sénatorial et euh si ce n'est
pas le cas quelles sont les mesures que
que vous comptez mettre en œuvre pour
rendre aux consommateurs ces 600
millions d'euros ou aux agriculteurs
d'ailleurs je vous remercie Nicole lepé
Renaissance mercredi matin j'ai assisté
à au discours de Madame
urcela Van derlen donc à Strasbourg
c'est la première fois qu'elle commence
et débute ses propos par la sécurisation
de l'approvisionnement de l'alimentation
en Europe avant d'autres sujets très
importants juste j'aurais voulu savoir
ce que vous en pensez de cette première
introduction donc de de Madame Ursula
van
derlen merci je vous remercie je madame
Aurélie trouvet groupe LFI merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
messieurs je voudrais revenir sur la
revente à perte qui est la nouvelle
solution miracle avancée par le
gouvernement bon je dois d'abord dire
que je pense qu'il y a pas un seul
économiste sérieux libéral ou pas qui
soutient une une telle une telle
proposition c'est une pratique interdite
dans la loi pour cause de concurrence
déloyale depuis 60 ans ça menace on le
sait les 5800 stations indépendantes
desessens mais aussi sans doute des
supermarchés en milieu rural et je
voudrais d'abord vous interpeller
là-dessus ma collègue inier d'ailleurs
n'a pas eu de réponse là-dessus monsieur
bonpard 900 emplois supprimés en France
par Carrefour mais n'y a-t-il pas un
risque encore de suppression d'emploi
avec une telle proposition de de revente
à perte puis je voudrais parler aussi
des consommateurs monsieur bonpard vous
dites vous n'êtes pas une ONG mais alors
n'y a-t-il pas le risque qui est
évidemment souligné par beaucoup
d'économistes que vous
rattrapiez en ce qui concerne évidemment
s'il y a revente à perdre sur l'essence
que vous rattrapiez sur les prix des des
produits alimentaires vous aurez compris
que je considère c'est une idée
désastreuse et vraiment le signe d'un
gouvernement qui sa plus quoi faireou
madame annelord babo
modem merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais évoquer les ce que vous posé
comme comme question sur la négociation
durant durant l'année c'est c'est une
vraie question mais ça nécessiterait
certainement que vous revoyez vos
méthodes aujourd'hui la renégociation
elle existe en cours d'année les
négociations intermédiaires elles
existent et et vous savez que vouslez
vous contourner en fait aujourd'hui la
loi avec des opération de trade
marketing avec la question des des des
pénalités logistiques donc aujourd'hui
il y a il y a des méthodes qui vous le
permettent j'aimerais savoir si vous
êtes prêt effectivement si on était
amené à négocier pendant toute l'année à
avoir des méthodes plus apaisées à
parler davantage effectivement du
produit et je rejoins mon collègu
puisqueaujourd'hui on parle beaucoup du
prix mais pas du produit et c'est c'est
bien regrettable et ça fait lien avec ce
que Monsieur Bompard disait aujourd'hui
je pense que votre métier c'est pas de
gagner des pares de marcher sur V petits
copains c'est nourrir les Français avec
des produits de qualité et aujourd'hui
la politique du prix bas elle tue nos
agriculteurs voire elle tue nos Français
elle tue les Français donc vous pouvez
rebondir peut-être là-dessus monsieur
bpard merci je vous remercie monsieur
Julien div LR merci monsieur le
Président merci d'avoir répondu monsieur
CTI monsieur chelcher sur le la la date
butoire et je pense que ça sera l'objet
de plusieurs débats à l'Assemblée moi je
Vraz VO lancer sur le srp+ 10 et l'avis
que vous vous faites de cette
application qui était initialement prévu
sur les produits alimentaires qui étai
tendu à d'autres produits qu'on puisse
avoir un retour et enfin Monsieur Michot
je vous ai posé une question tout à
l'heure vous mettez en cause l'Assemblée
nationale j' que vous puissiez nous
donner des noms de personnalités puisque
les propos de Michel Lecler visé
clairement des parlementaires je
voudrais que nous puissions avoir des
noms et puis également les arguments qui
permettent de tenir ces allégations
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
Président chassigne GDR oui je voudrais
revenir sur la dérive constatée de
l'approvisionnement alimentaire et des
arbitrages de la grande distribution ces
dernières semaines sur l'origine des
produits vendus pouvez-vous nous dire
comment a évolué la part des produits
d'importation dans vos linéaaires en
particulier les produits issus
d'importation extracommunautaires dans
les produits bruts sur les rayons
viandes et fruits et légumes ainsi que
dans les produits transformés des rayons
épiceries je vous remercie Monsieur
Dominique potier PS
oui vous avez à la main 3 milliards de
pub pour pour influencer l'imaginaire
des Français alors soyez respectueux de
l'Assemblée nationale répondez à deux
trois questions qui me paraissent
extrêmement pertinentes pour lesquelles
on na pas eu de réponse celle de Julien
div extrêmement importante peut pas
avoir d'allégation mensongère contre des
représentants de la nation la deuxième
question c'est la question d'André
chassigne concrètement sur quel produit
alimentairirees acheter à l'étranger
vous allez refaire les marges que vous
allez perdre sur la distribution enfin
ne pensez-vous pas que le gouvernement
l'amène une politique de gribouille en
mode panique en baissant la consommation
du pétrole sans toucher au superp prof
ni des énergéticiens ni de des
industriels qui ont des marges
exubérantes voilà merci et Monsieur
Richard Ramos modem une question simple
est-ce que vous mettrez dans vos rayons
des poulets Ukrainiens alors qu'ils ont
pas les normes je veux savoir si dans
dans les marques chez vous on aura ces
plusull là alors que nos nos producteurs
de vola ils sont à genou avec la grippe
aviaère et deuxièmement dire à Monsieur
bonpart et à vous tous on comprend que
pour prendre des parts de marché vous
répondez à un besoin des Français
d'acheter pas cher mais c'est le juste
prix qu' faut faut que vous nous aidiez
à faire acheter aux gens et quand on
rentre dans vos supermarchés on voit que
des promos on voit que des trucs comme
ça jamais vous nous parlez du bon
produit jamais vous nous dites qu'il a
du goût il a du goût parce qu'il a été
dans un bon herbage et donc vos
milliards d'euros en communication vous
les mettez parce que c'est le prix qui
vous fait gagner les uns les autres ces
parts de marché mais vous avez et j'ai
confiance en vous une part de
responsabilité sociétale avec les moyens
que vous avez et donc il faudra nous
dire régulièrement comment vous prenez
votre part non pas au prix bas mais au
juste prix je vous mercie je ne
souhaiterais frustrer aucun député donc
y a-t-il d'autres demandes de question
individuelles une fois deux fois trois
fois et bien écoutez messieurs il vous
reste une bonne dizaine de minutes 15
minutes très grand maximum pour conclure
je vous laisse vraiment totalement libre
de vos réponses mais est-ce que en 10
minutes nous pourrions répondre à ces
différentes questions qui souhaite
commencer monsieur chelcher allez-y euh
mesdames messieurs les députés je vais
prendre quelques questions pour
permettre à mes collègues aussi de
répondre tout d'abord madame la députée
effectivement sur France interre la
semaine dernière j'ai répondu à une
question deééas Salamé sur mais pourquoi
messieurs les distributeurs vous pouvez
pas faire comme Total et vous ne pouvez
pas plafonner le prix c'est à cette
question que j'ai répondu en expliquant
le mécanisme c'est vrai je l'ai fait
plusieurs fois en expliquant simplement
ce mécanisme
jamais j'avais dans la tête de le de le
regretter ou de demander de changer ce
fonctionnement je faisais simplement ce
que j'essaie souvent moi de faire de la
pédagogie pour les français pour
expliquer comment ça marche je vais
juste vous répondre ça il y a une
mécompréhension là-dessus je n'ai jamais
et vous ne trouverez aucune déclaration
de ma part qui dira on appelle à
remettre en cause le seil de vent à
perte sur la sanctuarisation des MPa
bien sûr que c'est une très bonne chose
et nous ne voulons pas évidemment
remettre en cause cette chosel moi je me
fais félicite du progrès du revenu des
agriculteurs bien évidemment bien
évidemment on a soutenu la mise en place
de de de de égalim et tant mieux si le
revenu agricole a progressé et ça faut
pas le remettre en cause faut pas
reculer on est en contact avec eux en
permanence et on a bien compris qu'ils
ne veulent pas reculer là-dessus ils ont
raison et il faut et et c'est pas ça qui
est en jeu et derrière il y a votre
question madame celle de de de la
souveraineté alimentaire on a une grande
respons stilité par rapport à ça et je
peux vous dire qu'on en a conscience et
quand on circule en France qu'on
construit des contrats tripartites qu'on
construit des choses avec des
coopérative j'étais sur scène l'autre
jour avec un président de grande
coopérativ breton c'est pour défendre ça
c'est pour défendre ça on n'est pas
parfait sans doute pas on l' on l'a bien
compris mais on essaie aussi de
construire des choses vertueuses et avec
cette toile de fond de de souverineté
sur l'achat en Europe c'est une
possibilité que vous devez nous laisser
dans le respect de la loi nous avons en
face de nous des acteurs puissants qui
achètent au niveau international je
prends même un exemple c'est Lidl Lidl
aujourd'hui est un grand intervenant en
France qui s'est fortement développé en
France qui achète au niveau européen
international pourquoi nous ne pourrions
pas juste pour quelques dizaines de
grandes entreprises avoir les moyens
quand elles font elles-mêm de la
péréquation en Europe les grandes
entreprises faut le comprendre font de
la péréquation en Europe elles vendent
plus cher en france pour vendre moins
cher en Espagne et cetera et c'est ça
qu'on est c'est là qu'on essaie de
chercher un peu de pouvoir d'achat pour
les Français sur le code du commerce oui
il il faudrait le revoir dans un esprit
de simplification avec cette grande idée
de nous permettre de discuter plus
souvent avec un objectif madame la
députée d'avoir des relations plus
apaisées ce qui met une grande tension
dans ce que nous vivons chaque année
c'est que nous sommes enfermés dans ces
3 mois de la loi actuelle c'est ces 3
mois ça nous oblige ça fait que les gens
se voient souvent et ça met une tension
supplémentaire libérons-nous de ça
faisons comme tous les pays étrangers
quand je vois mes collègues allemands il
me disent mais comment vous faites en
France pour fonctionner comme cela
euh voilà et sur pardon les produits
bruts et je m'arrêterai là pour laisser
mes collègues sur les produits bruts
l'engagement de système UC de l'achat
français déjà pour tous les produits à
notre marque et on ne dérogera pas
là-dessus et on on on on sera
très déterminé sur ce point-là il faut
défendre nos
agriculteurs je vous remercie qui
souhaite continuer je vais répondre
monsieur monsieur hamos non on a aucune
intention d'aller acheter des des
poulets en Ukraine c'est déjà pas le cas
et ce sera pas le cas à l'avenir les
poulets les viandes les œufs sont 100 %
français ne serait-ce que parce qu'on a
nos outils d'abattage comme vous le
savez en France le chez Intermarché le
vrai enjeu vous avez raison en fait ça
ça va être ça c'est-à-dire on a une
telle pression aujourd'hui sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est est-ce qu'on pte
tout c'est-à-dire ça fait quand même 3 4
ans le ministre ex-ministre aers est ici
pour le témoigner on a tous fait des
efforts un moment sur la qualité on a
poussé le bio et aujourd'hui ce serait
trop facile de remettre du premier prix
et de revoir les cahers des charges donc
on est en train de tenir mais c'est vrai
que c'est un enjeu qui est fort en tout
cas la volonté là j'ai mon patron des
achats devant moi c'est de par revenir
là-dessus parce qu'on ferait marche
arrière et on a une responsabilité
sociétale et on a notamment le prochain
enjeu qui va être climatique l'empreinte
carbone et cetera et le vrai risque
c'est de refaire des des premiers prix
et tomber dans du BAT de G mais en tout
cas c'est c'est pas la mission qu'on a
on fera tout pour pour évidemment
défendre défendre cette cause sur la
revente à perte alors on comprend la
démarche est louable du gouvernement
mesure exceptionnelle contexte
exceptionnel mais la réalité économique
c'est que en fait on aura on va pas
l'utiliser cette cette possibilité là
parce qu'à un moment si on fait ça on va
augmenter le prix des pattes donc on
n'est pas complètement cinglé donc bien
évidemment euh on nous propose le
dispositif mais vous pensez bien que en
plus il y a là pour le coup du coup je
vous parlais de la distorsion de
concurrence avec action on est dans les
territoires on a on a aucun intérêt à
tuer le petit pompiss qui pourra pas
évidemment le faire le SR P+ 10 chez
Intermarché c'est 70 millions alors vous
me croyez ou pas réellement il y a eu
une partie qui est allée en MPa
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu bien
évidemment des industriels qui sont
venus qui nous ont demandé de payer plus
cher et on a joué le jeu et il y a une
partie donc je vais reboucler désolé
monsieur de croa mais il y a une partie
en fait de ça qui nous a servi à aller
en complément des promos que nous
proposent les industriels en DPH le pH
les les les les paquets de couch c'est
quand même 10 15 € c'est des produits
très chers l'industriel il nous propose
à un moment 50 % et ça s'arrête là et
donc le jeu d'Intermarché ça a été
d'aller jusqu'à 90 % et on complète de
40 % l'avantage carte c'est du commerce
pour faire venir les gens et ça crédite
la carte et donc on est persuadé que des
des des des des remises de 8 ou 9 €
c'est quand même hyper important pour le
français donc c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste pour dire de grâce essayer de
sauver ça et puis euh dernier point sur
l'entreprise citoyenne vous savez moi je
suis fils d'agriculteur donc j'ai cette
responsabilité d'être dans un groupement
de chef d'entreprise mais j'oublie pas
mes origines et je peux vous assurer que
lui il a la pression c'est-à-dire j'ai
toujours défendu l'idée que on doit
construire des accords tripartites on a
des abattoirs donc la moitié de nos
agriculteurs sont déjà contractualisés
et c'est en fait moi c'est la seule
mission que je me donne je me dis je
suis à la tête d'un groupe de
distributeurs qui évidemment porte la
responsabilité de tous les mots de la
terre mais j'ai la conception
personnelle que la l'entreprise a une
responsabilité sociétale et donc tant
que ce sera côti à la tête des
Mousquetaires je peux vous assurer tout
n'est pas parfait mais que je défendrai
le plus possible le monde agricole ça
c'est une réalité merci Monsieur
michotou al je je vais commencer par je
vais pas commenter une émission de
télévision bien
évidemment puis je crois qu'à
l'Assemblée vous savez ce que
c'est complément d'enquête c'est un
témoignage alors je vais vous dire
clairement oui on fait du stock
stratégique oui ça nous arrive d'acheter
acheter quand il y a un bon un bon coût
à faire ou une bonne promotion oui on
achète maintenant dites-vous bien que
les gros fournisseurs en tout cas la la
grande majorité des fournisseurs
aujourd'hui contingente quand même les
les les opérations les opérations
commerciales et ne nous laissent pas
acheter ce que l'on veut l'affirmation
que dont don dont je doute la la la
véracité en tout cas qu'on peut remettre
en cause c'est le fait que on se servent
de ces stocks stratégiques ou en tout
cas des que de stocks stratégiques pour
se refaire la marche derrière je dis pas
que ça n'a jamais existé
en tout cas c'est pas l'objectif donc
c'est oui c'est c'est quelque chose qui
a existé qui existera peut-être
encore mais on le fait à l'intérieur de
la loi maintenant dire qu'on a acheté 25
% c'est-à-dire la totalité en une
commande en une commande la totalité sur
une centrale de là c'est c'est juste
quasiment pas possible et mais je laisse
je laisse l'auteur de ça le
dire je je je ne je ne cautionne pas sur
le SRP + 10 depuis le début je crois que
depuis le début on est toujours opposé
au SRP + 10 alors que ce soit Michel
Édouard Leclerc Philippe Michot tarton
pion chez Leclerc on a tous été d'accord
sur le fait que la SRP + 10 on était
opposé à ça et quand vous dites qu'on
est tous d'accord et les quatre d'accord
là pour le coup je suis pas je suis pas
certain qu'on partage tous ce point de
vue
mais les 600 millions je c'est alors je
remets pas en cause la capacité du Sénat
à faire des calculs mais je sais pas
d'où ça sort on a refait on a refait des
on a refait une étude par un
mathématicien reconnu un économiste
reconnu le rapport génique on a échangé
avec certains d'entre vous qui lui
effectivement ne regroupe pas ses
chiffres dit que si la SRP + 10 A a
coûté à peu près 6 % au ménages les
moins aisés donc on se dit que si on on
revenait dessus on pourrait renvoyer 6 %
à ces mêmes à ces mêmes consommateurs
euh et que de toute façon cette ces
sommes là je rejoins ce qui vient d'être
dit on les a remis dans les prix on est
l'enseigne la moins cher et on le
restera euh et et c'est souvent étonnant
alors je je suis pas Skiso mais c'est
assez étonnant de fois de nous dire mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites contre
l'inflation et mais vous les prix bas ça
tue tout ce que ça tout ce que ça tout
ce que ça touche et là je veux dire
c'est un équilibre assez compliqué à à
gérer parce que il faut pas d'inflation
il faut pas trop de prix bas faut être
pilep au milieu sur tous les produits et
l'ensemble de l'année alors oui on le
fait pour répondre monsieur Ramos à
votre question tout à l'heure sur notre
communication on fait de la
communication bien évidemment sur plein
de produits mais aussi on fait de la
communication sur des anances locales la
grande majorité de nos magasins sont
dans des territoires
ruraux pour répondre à Monsieur le
Député tout à l'heure
nous on est sur nos territoires pendant
25 30 ans nos enfants vont à l'école
avec les enfants des agriculteurs ils se
connaissent enfin faut arrêter 2
secondes on n pas non non non souvent il
y a pas que des écoles catholiques chez
moi il y a
qu'un chez moi il y a qu'un discé
agricole il y a qu'un discé agricole au
nebourg bien monsieur Michot allez-y
concluz je voudrais juste parce que il y
avait une autre question que l'on
m'avait posé
ouis alors ça je suis un capable de
répondre à cette question je suis je
sais pas si l'intention je connais
Michel mais je remets pas en cause ce
qu'il a dit bien évidemment
ouis alors je je sincèrement je me je
l'ai pas vu je je me défile pas parce
que si je dois dire les choses je les
dirai et et en toute franchise j'ai
aucun état d'ame sur le sujet mais je
suis incapable mais connaissant Michel
ça m'étonnerait qu'il ait mis le doigt
dans ce dans cette volonté du nemenschem
c'est pas notre truc le nemenchem on le
laisse aux autres on on le on le dit pas
c'est arrivé oui oui oui c'est arrivé
une fois arrivé c'est arrivé une fois on
est on est bien d'accord monsieur div
c'est arrivé une fois
c'était
commentationiteis attendez on ne va pas
s'interpeller on va va essayer de clore
on a eu un moment on a eu un moment
d'agassement onie monsieur Michot l'
gasp il vient vous comprenez aussi l'
gasp des parlementaires quand ils
entendent un leader de la grande
distribution qui dit il y a des
personnes dans notre pays qui sont au
pouvoir et qui ont un intérêt à avoir de
l'inflation et qui souhaitent de
l'inflation et donc quand monsieur div
entend ça quand les parlementaires
entend ça légitimement non mais
légitimement ils s'interrogent donc
c'est l'occasion de vous poser la
question vu que vous vous vous vous
émettez ce type d'accusation sur des
matinales de grande écoute nous
parlementaires qui sommes directement
interloqué par par ce type de
déclaration on se dit mais de qui
parle-t-il ou alors est-ce que c'est un
effet de communication qui vise à dire
l'inflation c'est pas moi c'est l'autre
c'est le voisin c'est le parlementaire
mais voilà je trouve que les question de
Monsieur div est parfaitement légitime
parce que sinon ça veut dire que c'est
de la dénonciation calomieuse en fait en
quelque sorte donc a quand même des des
conséquences à tout ça j'ai pas dit que
l'intervention de de Monsieur éta était
calomieuse enfin éondé c'est pas lui
quial compris compris faut pas inverser
les rôles monsieur mich allez-y je sens
vous êtes sensible quand même sur le
sujetite quand on fait respecter
monsieur mich quand on dit quand on dit
intérêt oui oui tout à fait tout à fait
monsieur je suis d'accord avec vous
quand quand parle comme ça je suis ça me
gêne de parler au nom de Michel parce
que c'est c'est j'assume complètement ce
qu'il dit j'ai pas de problème VI n voir
Monsieur mich la prochaine fois il pour
r il y a pas que Michel dans le
mouvement nombreux on est
nombreux bien je peux conclue donc je
vais juste je vais juste répondre quand
on parle d'intérêt c'est pas un intérêt
unique de personne c'est un intérêt
général parce qu'il est plus facile de
parler non non mais attendez laiss-moi
finir ma phrase et c'est quand même au
lieu de parler impôt on parleinflation
et c'est quand même mieux de parler
d'inflation que de parler d' hausse
d'impôt je pense que c'était dans ce
sens- là au fond mais je vais pas
polémiquer là aujourd'hui avec vous vous
êtes trop nombreux et je suis tout seul
très bien nous allons conclure donc avec
Monsieur bonpard par que vous avez pas
pris encore la parole sauf si vous
souhaitez pas répondre mais si vous bien
sûr allez-y Monsieur B je vais faire
très court comme vous me donnez la
parole en dernier je vous remercie
d'abord mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour vos question il en
ressortait ce qui fait le fondement de
notre métier les deux objectifs a priori
totalement contradictoires que nous
devons répondre en même temps l'objectif
de défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
Français vous avez été un certain nombre
d'entre vous et vous avez raison c'est
votre rôle à nous demander ce que nous
faisons pas seulement nous la filière
dans son ensemble avec les industriels
pour accompagner les Français baisser
les prix être au plus près possible de
leurs attentes dans un moment de
souffrance et vous le savez vous êtes
dans votre circonscription absolu de
restriction de privation de consommation
de bascule d'un certain nombre de nos
clients vers les Banques Alimentaires
vers des aides alimentaires structurées
et en même temps vous nous demandez vous
avez raison qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour accompagner le monde agricoolle
comment est-ce que vous faites pour que
les PME de l'industrie agroalimentaire
ailleent bien quel est votre rôle dans
cette transition que doit mener le monde
agricole c'est notre
métier c'est cette contradiction là qui
fait notre métier c'est aussi ce qui
fait sa noblesse parfois insuffisamment
reconnu mais c'est ça notre
contradiction à résoudre et soyez assuré
on vous a évidemment pas convaincu
surtout vous repartez avec des doutes
sur un certain nombre de sujets j'espère
aussi avec un certain nombre
d'explications sur d'autres que notre
objectif à nous chacun l'exprime à sa
manière avec ses mots avec avec ses
raisons d'être c'est d'amener la qualité
alimentaire au plus grand nombre c'est
ça notre métier c'est ça qui nous
passionne les uns et les autres c'est ça
qu'on fait avec le monde agricole ne
penser c'est pas que nous sommes ennemis
du monde agricole ce sont nos principaux
partenaires on ne fera pas la qualité
alimentaire pour tous sans le monde
agricole donc cette transition là c'est
celle qu'on fait mais on l'a fait en
essayant en même temps d'atteindre cet
objectif qui est notre quotidien dans
les magasins en permanence comment
est-ce qu'on fait au moment où il y a
une crise aussi forte pour un aussi
grand nombre de Français de leur
permettre de continuer à s'alimenter
convenablement c'est cette contradiction
là qui fait notre métier ne repartez pas
non plus avec l'impression que nous que
que le monde industriel est un ennemi
pour nous on vit pas toute la journée en
se disant que le monde industriel est un
ennemi d'abord il se divise en deux vous
avez raison nous avons les uns et les
autres de très bonnes relations avec les
PME agroalimentaires on signe très tôt
on s'entend globalement extrêmement bien
on n pas de difficultés à conclure les
négociations on a un point de friction
avec j'entendais parler tout à l'heure
de manque de concentration ou de trop
grande de de de de la grande
distribution nous sommes qu nous
pourrions être 10 je sais pas vous
recevez très souvent des d'autres
industries est-ce que vous avez 10
industriels en face de vous quand vous
avez l'industrie automobile les
industries comme ça parce qu'on aurait
pu ajouter Lidl auchamp casino Aldi et
bien d'autres donc c'est une industrie
où on se retrouve un certain nombre en
face de très grandes multinationales
nous sommes aussi des très grands
groupes on vous demande juste dans la
relation que nous avons avec eux de nous
faire confiance et nous laisser négocier
nous laisser discuter on n'est pas du
tout en train de toucher les PME on a
juste besoin que vous ayez confiance
dans le fait que nous négocions pour
baisser pour donner du pouvoir d'achat
au au aux Français et pour mener les
transitions alimentaires pour tous je
vous assure que même avec les grandes
multinationales on a plein de grands
projets de transformation qu'on mène
ensemble et puis dernière chose ayez
confiance dans le fait que quand on vous
donne des éléments de terrain on ne vous
dit pas n'importe quoi quand on vous dit
sur le DPH faites-nous confiance en
2024 il faut un moratoire sur
l'application de ces limitations de
promotion parce que quand on va dire au
français si jamais on leur dit au 1er
mars les promotions sur le dentifrice
sur les protections féminines sur
l'ensemble des produits d'hygiène de
première nécessité nous ne pouvons plus
faire des promotions ils vont pas
comprendre pourquoi on le fait parce que
ça n'a rien à voir avec le monde
agricole vous appliquerez cette mesure
en 2025 quand l'inflation sera baissée
nous le comprenons très bien mais pour
2024 faites-nous confiance il ne faut
pas rajouter une contrainte de plus et
une privation de plus au français en
tout cas merci beaucoup de votre écoute
merci beaucoup la confiance n'exclut pas
le contrôle comme le disait ma
grand-mère absolument donc nous sommes
là pour faire confiance mais aussi
contrôler et vous avez raison de
rappeler qu'ici il y a pas de gentil de
méchant et que on est à l'écoute des
acteurs économiques je veux juste avoir
une confirmation parce que c'est utile
pour la façon don nous allons légiférer
sur le projet de loi que je comprenne
bien sur la mesure de vente à perte que
certains ont répondu monsieur monpard
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que vous ne
vendriez pas à perte de l'essence vous
l'avez très clairement dit je
continuerai à faire des opérations merci
juste d'avoir une confirmation des des
acteurs économique pour qu'on soit bien
clair de ce que nous avons entendu
monsieur chelcher vous avez indiqué que
même si vous aviez déclaré sur France
sint en réponse à Madame la Salamé que
vous ne pouviez pas vendre à perte parce
que il y avait l'interdiction de vente à
perte vous venez de dire que il n'était
pas dans votre intention de remettre en
cause l'interdiction de vente à perte
c'est ce que vous avez dit pour des
raisons économiques il sera pas possible
aux entreprises aux PME du groupe
Système U de faire massivement des
opérations de vente à perte sur le je
vous remercie monsieur Cotillard vous
avez indiquer que même si Vous remerciez
le gouvernement de son écoute sur le
sujet Vous ne vous saisiriez pas de la
mesure parce que vous n'êtes pas idiot
je vos propres mots et que vous ne
souhaitez pas vous rattraper sur
d'autres produits cela veut dire que
vous ne vendrez pas à perdre de
l'essence de votre côté également c'est
exactement ça bien je n'ai pas eu la
réponse de Monsieur Michot pour Leclerc
monsieur Leclerc vous saisirez-vous oui
ou non de cet outil qui a été proposé
nos entreprises ne sont pas fabriquées
pour faire de la vente à perte donc nous
ne font pas de vente à perdre sur le
carburant je vous remercie cela veut
donc dire que sur cet outil qui vous été
proposé aucun d'entre vous n'a souhaité
se saisir de cette ce dispositif et
aucun d'entre vous ne se saisirait de ce
dispositif s'il existait ne travesti pas
vos propos en le
disant je vous remercie cela va susciter
quelques amendements j'imagine sur cet
article 2 en tout cas merci euh beaucoup
messieurs pour votre présence et vos
réponses n'hésitez pas à revenir nous
voir vous l'avez vu notre assemblée est
accueillante et elle préfère toujours
échanger directement avec les acteurs
économiques plutôt que de les écouter
sur les matinales radio même si bien
évidemment on est très heureux de vous
écouter également à la radio et à la
télé